Easy.
Omegalo. Easy.
Moin. Oh ne.
Was ist denn das hier? Ach jetzt kommt der Mist schon wieder.
Was ist das denn?
Ich hab das eben offen gehabt, bestimmt 5 Minuten
und dieses komische Overlay-Ding
ist nicht erschienen.
Aber kaum gehe ich online, erscheint das.
Na auch geil.
Anscheinend kommt das nur, wenn man auch online
ist auf dem Channel.
Das ist natürlich ziemlich hängen geblieben.
Heißt
wir müssen das hier zumachen
die
VM öffnen und
Chatterino anmachen.
Oh, hier ist sogar noch an.
Keine Ahnung, was Twitch
sich gedacht hat, dass es eine gute Idee ist.
Ah ja.
Ich glaub mal, das müssen wir
jetzt neu starten an der Stelle.
Und
wir müssen
als Hintergrundbild
Oh.
Oh Mist.
Der Wallpaper-Generator
ist kaputt.
Hat Chat-GPT doch nicht so
einwandfrei programmiert, wie es ausschaut, hä?
Weil eigentlich ist 8.45 Uhr.
Sollte da nicht Sonnenaufgangsbild kommen?
Äh.
Jaja, der schläft noch.
So. Ich hab jetzt erstmal hier
den Chat offen, weil
Twitch selbst geht ja anscheinend
nicht mehr. Ich mach nochmal schnell
ein Update hier von der Kiste.
Schadet ja nix.
Wir machen jetzt zwar nix
da drinnen, aber Update ist nie verkehrt.
Er schläft noch, ja.
Es ist halt
ziemlich doof, dass
der Chat nur funktioniert, wenn man eingeloggt
ist. Ich könnte mir
einfach einen
Fake-Account machen.
Einen Twitch-Fake-Account.
Und mich damit einloggen.
Weil ich will mich nicht
auf meinem Streaming-Rechner in Twitch einloggen.
Wer weiß nicht,
dass ich irgendwas, was auch immer,
fällt jetzt nix ein, aber
nicht, dass ich irgendwas leake.
Was
vielleicht ja sein könnte.
Ich mein, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist, gibt's das Problem
halt gar nicht. Ja, da kann man nix leaken.
Ja, ich glaub, das hab ich sogar noch
offen. Darkseid, ich glaub, das
hab ich sogar noch offen.
Wir machen erstmal kurz Update.
PN, ja, JavaScript-Shit, man.
Egal, muss jetzt sein. So wie's ausschaut.
Tschüss.
Ja, Chat, hab ich die Woche
irgendwas verpasst? Ich hab nicht
so viel rumgeguckt.
Hab ein bisschen Hacker-News gelesen. Da war jetzt eigentlich
nix Großartiges, außer,
dass sich alle drüber
beschwert haben oder
alle drüber lustig gemacht haben,
dass die Starship-Rakete
explodiert ist.
Ansonsten war die Woche irgendwas
Spannendes noch.
Ja, es gab einen Blog-Artikel
von irgendeinem Ex-Amazon-Mitarbeiter,
der sich darüber beschwert hat, dass er zu viel
verdient und
dafür zu wenig arbeiten muss. Wobei das nicht
wirklich der Inhalt
von dem Artikel war, aber man könnte
ihn so interpretieren, ja. Den wollte ich
auch noch mit euch angucken, irgendwann im
Stream. Ja, der hat sich drüber beschwert,
dass man in der IT zu viel Geld verdient
und zu wenig dafür machen muss.
So, was war denn die Woche noch? Irgendwas
Spannendes? Wir gucken gleich mal GitHub-Trends
rein. Wenn wir schon dabei sind.
Yes, yes, yes, yes. Installation, continue.
Sag ich mal hier, GitHub-Trends, was haben wir denn da?
Lass mich raten, Chat. Ohne jetzt gucken zu müssen.
AI, AI, AI, AI, einmal Krypto, AI, AI, okay.
Trending range, date, this week, AI, Auto-GPT,
da habe ich ein Video zu offen, da habe ich
ein Video zu offen von, von der CT, glaube
ich sogar. Wann war denn hier das erste,
jetzt ist es schon ein bisschen her, aber da ist
Heavy, Heavy Development hier.
Auto-GPT, okay, AI, AI, AI, was? Okay, das ist
wahrscheinlich nicht mal AI, oder? Das ist, ach so,
das liegt daran, weil ich Updates gemacht habe im
Hintergrund. Okay, da kann Firefox gar nichts dafür.
Das ist, weil ich geupdatet, weil ich Firefox geupdatet
habe im Hintergrund. Ich habe schon gedacht,
Firefox hat mal wieder den Geist aufgegeben.
Was?
So ein Typ von einer Gruppe, die Mods für Nintendo
konsolieren, muss irgendwie 14 Millionen Strafe
bezahlen. Das habe ich tatsächlich gar nicht
mitgekriegt. Aber Nintendo versteht da keinen
Spaß. Das ist echt so ein ziemlicher Kackladen,
was Mods und Fan-Projekte angeht. Zumal bei vielen
der Sachen wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal direkt
Nintendo irgendeinen Verlust erleidet, aber die
sind da, sind da halt ziemlich, ja, angepisst immer
drauf. Okay, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, Beautiful Design
Components. Okay, lass mal gucken, wie beautiful
JavaScript sein kann. Sieht sehr zweifarbig aus, aber
tatsächlich scheint es ganz okay auszuschauen. Was ist,
was ist Radix UI, Alter? Leute, ich habe jetzt bestimmt die
letzten zwei, drei Monate keine Frontend-Sachen
mehr gemacht und schon habe ich keine Ahnung mehr
von Frontend-Frameworks. Ist das irgendein React-Krempel
oder was ist das? Was ist das überhaupt? Was? React.
Achso, ja gut, kein Wunder. Normal verwende ich kein
React, da kenne ich mich auch nicht mit aus. Okay, ich
weiß nicht, was es sein soll, aber im Zweifelsfall
AI. Ja, AI. Tatsächlich mal keine AI, sondern eine
NoSQL-Datenbank. Why not? Mach mal was. Der NoSQL-Hype
ist ja bisschen rum, schon so die letzten Jahre.
NoSQL-Datenbanken sind jetzt halt da und es interessiert
halt keinen mehr großartig, dass sie da sind. AI, AI,
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich irgendeine Notiz-Anwendung
oder so, China-Chinesen-Notiz-Anwendungen, okay. AI, AI,
AI, AI, ja, Mobile-Anwendung juckt mich nicht, Stonks, AI-based wahrscheinlich, Java, interessiert uns nicht, AI, AI, ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist, aber im Zweifelsfall AI, auch AI und ich habe keine Ahnung, was es sein soll, China-Chinesen-Zeug, okay, alles klar, okay, es ist nicht so viel Spannendes dabei, was,
nicht so viel Spannendes dabei, was normale Projekte angeht, oder, aber wenigstens, okay, die Musik-Lautstärke kann sich nicht entscheiden, moin, Jantari, danke schön für den Sub, ja, war jetzt nicht so viel Spannendes dabei, Leute, also, weiß nicht, also, GitHub-Trends waren auch schon mal trendiger und spannender für mich,
klar, ich meine, was sich im Bereich AI-Entwicklung tut, ist schon cool zu beobachten, aber ich würde halt vielleicht auch mal ganz gerne noch ein paar,
andere interessante Projekte sehen, als immer nur AI, gibt ja durchaus auch noch andere Sachen, die ganz spannend sind, ja, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel muss ich unbedingt wissen, was das neueste JavaScript-Framework ist, das ist der Krempel, der früher immer auf GitHub getrendet ist, ja, jede Woche irgendein neues JavaScript-Framework, jetzt trendet aktuell AI, wir können nochmal eine Sache gucken, also, just for fun, was trendet denn im Bereich .NET C-Sharp,
nicht, dass da jetzt super krasse Trends gebe, weil die, es geht da meistens ein bisschen dran vorbei, oh, komm, wir gucken mal, was in C++ trendet, okay, wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich AI, aber, aber, komm, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht's, okay, der Wii U-Emulator, komische C++-Library von Facebook,
Building SIGGIS Modules, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist, ich habe wirklich, hat irgendjemand einen Plan, was das ist, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich AI, Steam-Zeug,
Testing-Framework, ja, das ist mit C++ aber auch nötig, PyTorch, also, die, die PyTorch-Basics, so, Protobuf, MediaPipe, KeyPass, cool, KeyPass trendet, hätte ich ja nicht, damit hätte ich jetzt wirklich nicht gerechnet, ein Window-Manager, ja, ein bisschen AI,
Foxy, den kenne ich tatsächlich mal zur Abwechslung, auch wenn es ein C++-Projekt ist, Highbind,
Swift, Moment, Swift ist in C++ programmiert, ich hätte gedacht, wenn schon, in Objective-C, aber den Mist wollte sich wahrscheinlich nicht mal Apple geben, oder, so wie es ausschaut, Elektron, ja gut, was sonst, was sonst, Elektron, selbstverständlich Elektron,
FPS-Unlocker für Roblox, oh, das hat mir gefehlt, jetzt habe ich alles gesehen, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll, okay, ich muss sagen, die C++-Trends waren fast interessanter als die, als die Overall-Trends,
so, und jetzt aber kurz bei C-Sharp gucken,
wenn sie, PowerShell, ja gut, ihr, falls ihr es nicht wisst, man kann mittlerweile sogar PowerShell unter Linux installieren, ich wüsste nicht, warum man das machen sollte, aber es funktioniert, und es hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen 74 Upvotes,
wer, wer, warum upvoted man PowerShell, also, also, Leute, die das upvoten, die benutzen das ja wahrscheinlich auch, aber warum, was machen, okay, ich weiß warum, die entwickeln unter Windows, äh, die entwickeln unter Linux,
Windows-Automatisierung, oder, was anderes, was anderes kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, warum man sich PowerShell unter, unter Windows, äh, unter Linux installieren sollte,
Sharp VX-Dump, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll, China, China, China, ah, obviously, ähm, klar, oder, was es macht, also, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, ihr habt's verstanden, also, ich, okay, Moment, Moment, Translator,
Google, irgendwas mit WeChat, Google Translate, WeChat-Klein-Forensics, which can we obtain, aha, aha, okay, quasi, WeChat, WeChat-Datenabgreifen für alle, sonst kann das nur die, die China-Chinesen-Regierung, WeChat-Datenabgreifen, und hiermit können's alle, oder so, okay,
oh, nee, jetzt hab ich das zugemacht, wollte ich gar nicht, wollte die eins zurück, aber ich verwende kein WeChat, also, insofern,
tja, so, Chat-GPT, Cloudflare-Scanner, was, was scannt man denn bei Cloudflare, äh, okay, absolut keine Ahnung, was das sein soll, Integrate Cutting Edge, ah, ähm, Machine Learning,
okay, seriously, ich mein, bei dem Namen kommt ja nun wirklich keiner darauf, dass es irgendwelches AI-Zeug ist, aber es ist AI-Zeug, Open Terminatry, okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz sinnig,
wenigstens mal was, was mir was sagt, Maui, geh mir bloß fort, wenn ich Maui, wenn ich Maui,
schon sehe, kriege ich jewelry-Anfälle, also, Maui ist wirklich was, wo ich mich nicht näher mit auseinandersetzen möchte,
ich fand den Vorgang ja schon Schrott, und ich find Maui ja auch Schrott, was ich bisher gesehen hab,
To-Do-RP, ja, das braucht unbedingt 1800 Sterne,
ASP.NET Core selbst, okay, versteh ich, DNS-Server, ein, ein, ein DNS-Server in .NET, warum hat der 2000 Sterne,
ach so, das ist so ein, so ein,
Eyehole oder Ad,
Adblock-DNA, aber warum?
But why?
Also was ist an dem so viel geiler?
Weiß nicht.
Windows Power, das PF, äh, okay.
Das WPF nicht aussieht
wie 2005, aber
WPF unter der Haube immer noch ist wie
2005, gibt es anscheinend das da.
Sieht dann, sieht dann
moderner aus,
aber ja, sieht aus wie moderner Windows,
wie modernes Windows-Shit-Zeug,
aber es ist unter der Haube
immer noch WPF von
2005 und man will es normalerweise
nicht verwenden.
Demo-Anwendungen, Blazer,
auch so ein Ding, was
mich nicht juckt.
AI, Unity-Zeug,
stimmt, warum ist da nicht mehr Unity-Zeug dabei
bei den C-Sharp-Trends?
OpenCV-Wrapper
für .NET, okay.
Kernel-Mode-Maus-Acceleration,
okay, was zum Teufel soll das sein?
hey,
Windows
allows for acceleration
of mouse input in the raw input stream.
Warum will man überhaupt
Maus-Acceleration haben?
Leute, es gibt 30 Milliarden
Guides, wo man irgendwelche Settings
umstellen muss, dass man auf gar keinen Fall
Maus-Acceleration hat, okay?
Warum will man denn unbedingt Maus-Acceleration haben?
Für Touchpad und sowas,
okay, das kann ich mir
sogar vorstellen.
Okay, das ist zumindest
ein Treiber,
dass man Maus-Acceleration bekommt,
selbst wenn Games
RAW Maus-Input verwenden.
Eigentlich eine sehr
coole Idee, auch wenn ich mich wirklich frage,
warum man das benutzen sollte, aber in Ordnung.
Okay, okay, meinetwegen, meinetwegen.
Okay, nichts wirklich Spannendes dabei.
Ups.
Haben wir mal nicht schlecht reingeguckt zu haben.
Kannst du einen Rasenmäher-Roboter empfehlen?
Nee, nicht wirklich. Ich hab keinen.
Und ich sehe aktuell auch noch
nichts, dass ich
mir einen kaufe. Ja.
Also, wir
haben ja letztens dieses Video geguckt.
Also, könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern?
Wir haben doch letztens das Video geguckt,
wo, wo
so ein Wireless ohne,
ohne Kabel gezeigt
wurde, so ein Rasenmäher-Roboter.
Normalerweise muss man ja immer
immer so Drähte
verlegen.
Unterm Rasen,
dass der weiß, wo es anfängt und wo es aufhört.
Und letztens haben wir ein Video geguckt,
wo das nicht so war.
Aber die Dinger wurden
mit Batterien betrieben,
was ich auch schon ziemlich beschissen fand.
Und nichtsdestotrotz
sah das Ding auch nicht so aus, als kommt es gut durch
meinen Garten durch. Also insofern,
nee, nee,
ich glaub nicht,
dass ich mir in nächster Zeit einen Rasenmäher-Roboter
kaufen würde.
Ähm, der Sohn vom Nachbar war
letztens bei uns im Garten, hat Rasen gemäht.
Ich würde sagen, das ist,
der ist besser als ein Rasenmäher-Roboter.
Und er wollte dafür auch nicht so viel Geld
haben.
Also bleibe ich lieber
dabei,
als mir
einen Rasenmäher-Roboter zu kaufen.
Das ist gut in CI-CD,
warum ist PowerShell dort gut
und warum kann ich nicht einfach irgendein
x-belieblich anderes Skript machen? Warum muss PowerShell sein?
Ja, das verstehe ich sogar noch.
Das verstehe ich noch. Okay, ja.
Oder meinst du, um
in irgendeiner Pipeline zu testen, ob die PowerShell-Skripte
prinzipiell syntaxmäßig
korrekt und sowas sind.
Der ist glaube ich mittlerweile sogar auch schon,
nein, nein, 18 ist der noch nicht. Der dürfte wahrscheinlich so 16
sein oder so.
Der ist der Sohn vom Nachbar.
Hey, der hat aber gefragt,
ob er wieder mal Rasen mähen kann. Klar,
auf geht's, let's go.
Rasen mähen, solange ich es nicht selbst machen muss, beste.
Den habe ich mit 20 Euro in die Hand gedrückt, der war da irgendwie
zwei Stunden unterwegs, hat Rasen gemäht.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich schlecht,
der Stundenlohn, oder?
Okay. Und sonst
war noch irgendwas spannendes, Leute.
Es muss doch irgendwas gewesen sein, die Woche, was ich verpasst habe.
Lasst uns mal...
Ja, ne, stimmt eigentlich.
Ja.
Lasst uns mal
gucken,
ob es schon... Gibt es schon die heise Wochenzusammenfassung?
Ich glaube nicht.
Sackt immer ziemlich.
Die bringen die Wochenzusammenfassung
immer so raus, dass ich sie nicht sehe.
Und
man sieht,
also man findet die dann auch nicht,
wenn man da nachguckt, also insofern...
Die haben eine Wochenzusammenfassung,
aber ich finde sie nicht.
Replay, genau.
Replay
heißt der Mist.
Die heise Suche ist natürlich
auch Müll.
Dann halt nicht, ja.
Okay, das kann ich verstehen,
da hast du recht.
Ich bräuchte halt einen Rasenmäher-Roboter,
der gut bei mir passt in den Garten.
Der halt auch nicht an den Wurzeln hängen bleibt.
Wo ich auch keine...
Ja, irgendwelche...
Drähte
verbuddeln muss und...
Ist halt nix dabei aktuell,
wo ich denke, ja, das will ich haben.
Lasst uns mal kurz checken, irgendwas stimmt mit meinem...
...meiner
Lautstärke nicht, oder?
Ne, doch, doch, doch, alles gut.
Um nicht zu sagen,
exzellent.
Ansonsten gibt es irgendwas spannendes zu erzählen.
Ich überlege gerade, ich meine, das ist jetzt quasi
die dritte Woche.
Dritte Woche auf der neuen Arbeit ist jetzt um.
Nächste Woche noch,
dann bin ich einen Monat da.
Es geht sehr schleppend voran.
Also, ich entdecke immer wieder,
dass irgendwelche
Berechtigungen nicht funktionieren.
Und dass alles sehr
schwerfällig ist,
da in dem Laden, also sprich...
Du, das Letzte muss ich euch erzählen.
Aber gut, ich meine, die haben es wenigstens
im Vergleich zum letzten Laden ganz gut gemacht.
Die sind nicht nur schwerfällig,
das hat wenigstens ein gewisses System dahinter,
warum es schwerfällig ist.
Letztens, auch geil, Leute,
passt mal auf, ich habe euch ja schon erzählt, dass es bei mir
auf der Arbeit super restriktiv ist,
was du machen darfst, ja?
Dass sie zum Beispiel mir einen Windows-Notebook gegeben haben,
wo ich nichts drauf ausführen darf und sowas.
Gut, mittlerweile habe ich glücklicherweise
eine Linux-VM, wo ich was drauf machen kann.
Aber die Linux-VM, jetzt kommt ja der Hit, ja?
Ich habe eine Linux-VM
mir erstellt,
wo ich Root-Rechte drauf habe
und die hat keinen Internet-Access.
Man kann sich irgendeinen Proxy setzen,
aber der Proxy funktioniert
auf der Linux-Kiste nicht richtig,
weil, und jetzt kommt der Hit,
weil dieser Proxy irgendwie
HTTPS aufbrechen möchte
und meine Linux-Kiste sagt
Nope, gibt's nicht.
Ich wollte einen Docker-Container
bauen, beziehungsweise
ich wollte ein Container-Image bauen
aus dem Docker-File, nur mal so,
dass ihr mal wisst, mit was für banalen
Sachen ich mich rumschlagen muss
und was ewig dauert.
Ich wollte einen Docker-Container bauen
und, also aus dem Docker-File,
was mir jemand per Mail geschickt hat.
So, Docker-Container bauen.
Also, was mache ich?
Naja, Docker-File rüber, Docker-Build.
Erstmal festgestellt, Mist,
gibt ja kein Docker auf der Kiste.
Also, Podman installiert,
übers Repo, ging,
okay, Build, festgestellt,
ah, die Kiste kommt nicht ins Internet.
Ja, und wie baue ich jetzt Docker-Images?
Ich meine, muss ja irgendwie die Base-Images ziehen, ja?
Da baue ich nicht ins Internet.
Also, ich habe schon überlegt,
ob ich irgendwelche abenteuerlichen SSH-Tunnel mache,
aber erstens
nicht sicher, ob das geht
und zweitens, ob das gewollt ist.
Ne, die haben ein,
die haben ein Docker-Proxy, wusste ich gar nicht,
dass es sowas gibt.
Man muss alle Docker-Files changen auf den
Docker-Proxy und das da rüberziehen ist auch
äußerst weirdchamp.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
man arbeitet dort echt im Schneckentempo,
weil es so restriktiv ist.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich muss,
ich muss mir halt, ich muss mich da dran gewöhnen,
indem ich mir sage,
Leute, die bezahlen mir
so viel Geld, dass es
eigentlich egal ist, ob ich da
sonderlich produktiv bin oder nicht.
Ich meine, es liegt ja nicht an mir. Ich würde ja,
wenn ich könnte, ja?
Aber es dauert halt alles ewig lang
und ist super kompliziert.
Das heißt, im Prinzip
muss ich mir einfach nur sagen, ey,
die überweisen mir so viel Geld,
auch wenn ich nix mache,
und da muss
mir's egal sein.
Und das ist ja schon wirklich nur ein Haufen Kohle, also
insofern, unterm Strich gehe ich halt
immer noch arbeiten, um Geld zu verdienen
und dann arbeite ich halt nix und krieg dafür Geld, ist auch okay.
Ich hab's mir ja nicht ausgedacht.
Ist ja nicht, dass ich nichts machen will,
aber so sind halt die
Workflows dort. Ich würde nicht
sagen, dass es in der alten Firma besser war, was
das angeht. Manche Sachen waren tatsächlich besser
von der Tech, also von der,
wie restriktiv das ist,
ja, man konnte Teams ordentlich benutzen
und sowas. Die haben sogar in Teams,
ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, die haben sogar in Teams
ausgeschaltet, dass man Nachrichten editieren darf.
Habt ihr das, wusstet ihr,
dass es überhaupt geht?
Wusstet ihr, dass man in Teams ausschalten kann,
dass man Nachrichten editieren kann?
Das war mir so überhaupt nicht bewusst,
dass es möglich ist, das auszuschalten.
Kann man ausschalten, haben die ausgeschaltet.
Nicht, dass da einer erst reinschreibt,
hier, keine Ahnung, was Böses,
das editiert.
Keine Ahnung, was mit denen los ist.
Also, was das angeht, ist wirklich ein bisschen
ätzend.
Ist denen bewusst, naja,
gut, mehr als meckern und sagen, kann ich's
ja nicht. Ja, ja, ich gehe
schon davon aus, dass es denen bewusst ist.
Warum?
Tja, das weiß ich auch nicht.
Löschen kannst du die Nachricht
natürlich auch nicht. Du kannst weder editieren,
noch löschen.
Ja, Leute, das wäre jetzt ja zu einfach, wenn du es
einfach löschen könntest. Einmal
eingeschickt für immer da, so wie bei ICQ
quasi. Und das war richtig peinlich,
ja. Ich habe unseren
IT
Abteilungsleiter angeschrieben und habe
mich bei seinem Namen vertippt.
Und ich konnte es nicht editieren.
Weil Teams so restriktiv eingestellt
ist.
Tja, was soll ich machen, ja?
Man heißt halt falsch in der Message.
Ich hätte es ja korrigiert,
wenn Teams mich gelassen hätte.
Also das ist tatsächlich
echt wirklich ätzend, ja.
Dass es so restriktiv ist.
Der Rest ist wirklich, also ich muss sagen,
der Rest ist, also sowohl
Team als auch Projektmäßig,
als auch die Firma an sich, ist
wirklich mega nice.
Aber
das Restriktive ist schon ganz schön
ganz schöner Müll.
Deswegen, ich muss mir
einfach immer sagen, Leute,
bezahlt mich, die bezahlen mich auch dafür,
wenn ich nichts mache. Weil, wie gesagt,
an mir liegt es nicht.
Kann man damit DSGV?
Keine Ahnung, das probiere ich nicht.
Ist es nicht schwierig, deine Ziele einzuhalten?
Leute, die Ziele, zumindest das, was ich mitgekriegt
habe an Zielen, das ist so
ja, konservativ alles
geschätzt, das hältst du locker ein.
Ja, so ungefähr ist das.
Ja, so, das ist eine ganz
gute Beschreibung. Naja gut,
ich meine, die Ziele, die werden ja auch dementsprechend
so gestellt, dass man das in diesen
ups, ups, dass man das unter diesen
Bedingungen erreichen kann. Und wenn ich
halt, gut, ich meine,
es geht halt nicht schneller, weil ich
an allen möglichen
Stellen das nicht so machen kann,
wie man es normalerweise
effektiv machen würde.
Ja, ich habe eine Linux-VM.
Ich habe sogar schon meine ZSH
Config da drüber. Das Problem ist,
dass diese Linux-VM nirgends wohin kommt, auch nicht
ins Internet, nicht nix nachinstallieren kann, beziehungsweise
nicht
wirklich gut damit arbeiten kann. Ich wollte letztens
zum Beispiel mal
Link-AD, so ein Surface-Mesh
per Helm installieren im Kubernetes-Cluster.
Ging nicht, weil, ja gut,
ich konnte halt keinen Helm-
Chart hinzufügen, weil
das ist halt im Internet normalerweise.
Das geht nicht.
Das muss dann vielleicht auch
durch irgendeinen komischen Proxy durch, was auch
immer. Es ist sehr
Schnecken-Tempomäßig dort
zu arbeiten. Und jetzt habe ich
eine neue Aufgabe, das wird auch was, Leute.
Habe ich auch gesagt, ja,
gucke ich mir mal an.
Und zwar,
wie man einen Kubernetes-Cluster
monitort, und jetzt haltet euch fest,
nicht etwa irgendwie mit
Zabbix oder mit Prometheus
oder sowas, nein, mit
Checkmk. Hat irgendjemand
von euch schon mal Checkmk benutzt?
Also das, was ich
bisher davon gesehen habe, macht
ganz normal einen Eindruck, aber
es macht ein bisschen den Eindruck,
naja, es ist nicht mehr so ganz
taufrisch, das Produkt.
Ja, also ich kann
selbst noch nicht viel zu sagen, ich habe damit jetzt
persönlich noch nicht viel gemacht. Weiß nicht, hat jemand
von euch schon mal Checkmk benutzt?
Also genau, es macht ein bisschen altbackenen
Eindruck. Was ich bisher gesehen habe,
ist ganz okay, das wirkte ein bisschen wie
Nagios in modernerem Gewand,
auch vom Webinterface und allem.
Aber durchaus brauchbar, ja, also es ist nicht
so, es machte vor allem
den Eindruck, als ist es
auch für Normalsterbliche
konfigurierbar
im Vergleich zu Zabbix. Zabbix haben
wir hier auch schon im Stream
gemacht, also Zabbix ist äußerst weirdchamp,
wie da was konfiguriert wird, versteht eigentlich keine Sau.
Also Checkmk macht ja den Eindruck, als
versteht man auch halbwegs, was man da macht.
So, und jetzt
muss ich gucken,
jemand ein Kubernetes
Cluster mit
Checkmk monitort.
Und da gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten, soweit ich das
rausgefunden habe, und
alle sind irgendwie kacke.
Das ist auch geil.
Bei dem einen muss man irgendwie drei verschiedene
Agents in seinem Kubernetes Cluster installieren
und halt auch gucken, dass man die up-to-date hält.
Was natürlich auch ziemlich,
ziemlich Mist ist.
Ähm, SNMP
und Checkmk sind zwei komplett
unterschiedliche paar Tools. SNMP
ist ein Protokoll, um ja
Eigenschaften und State von
Netzwerkgeräten abzufragen und Checkmk
ist ein Monitoring Tool. Also, hä?
Das eine hat
doch mit dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun. Oder meinst
du den Agent? Du verwendest
weiterhin Checkmk, aber du benutzt keine
Agent mehr, sondern fragst über SNMP
ab. Tja.
So, und jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wie man das
hinkriegt. Das ist alles Mist, was ich rausbekommen habe.
Also, die ganzen Lösungen dafür sind irgendwie Mist.
Du kannst entweder in deinem Kubernetes Cluster
Checkmk Agents
installieren. Dann hast du da Zugriff
auf Gott und die Welt an Werten
und Metriken. Aber du musst dich um die Agents
kümmern und die musst du auch ab und zu updaten und
dass halt Agents dich abkacken können und was auch immer.
Das ist halt auch nicht so schön. Außerdem muss
dann Checkmk von außen irgendwie
zugelassen sein, auf deinen Cluster zuzugreifen.
Was auch irgendwie
doof ist. Dann gibt es die
Möglichkeit Prometheus
abzufragen, aber selbst das ist
auch nicht schön integriert in Checkmk.
Also die beste Variante,
die ich bisher gefunden habe, also es gibt
zwei gute Varianten, die ich bisher gefunden
habe, um Checkmk
Kubernetes Sachen abzufragen. Und zwar
das erste ist, dass
man Managed Prometheus benutzt.
Irgendwie von
Google zum Beispiel.
Und
darüber quasi Checkmk
mit diesem Endpunkt irgendwie verbindet.
Und das zweite ist, man
verwendet von Checkmk das
Cloud Plugin, was
die Google Cloud mit Monitoring
Metriken abgreifen kann, wo auch
paar Kubernetes Sachen drin sind.
Das müsste relativ out of the box
funktionieren und man braucht halt keine Agents.
Für alles, wo man Agents installieren muss, um die man
sich selbst kümmern muss, ist halt
Mist.
Weil dann kann ich den ganzen Kram auch selber machen.
Dann brauche ich keine Managed Lösung.
Ich bin eh, ich finde es
äußerst weirdchampig, wie die dort
Cloud Sachen verwenden.
Die verwenden zwar Cloud,
aber sie machen die Sachen trotzdem selber.
Zum Beispiel,
ja wir haben einen Managed Kubernetes Cluster
bei Google, aber wir wollen einen eigenen
Ingress Controller verwenden. Warum?
Man weiß es nicht so genau, anstatt
den Google Ingress zu verwenden.
Wir wollen Kubernetes Cluster Backup machen.
Ne, wir verwenden ein eigenes Backup Tool,
anstatt
das eingebaute in der Cloud.
Und solche Geschichten, wo ich mir denke,
ja warum sind wir dann überhaupt
in der Cloud, wenn wir nichts von der Cloud
verwenden wollen.
Secret Management über die
Cloud? Ne, wir wollen ein eigenes Secret Management
Tool benutzen.
Das ist halt komplett Banane,
dass die alles selbst machen wollen, aber
das in der Cloud aufbauen.
Du kannst dir das Geld theoretisch fast sparen.
Da geht es zu Digital Ocean,
da kostet es ein Drittel.
Kriegst du zwar die ganzen Services nicht dabei,
aber,
gut, die haben wahrscheinlich Probleme mit
es muss in Europa sein und was auch immer,
aber dann kostet es dich ein Drittel,
du kriegst auch alles was du brauchst,
und wenn du die anderen Services eh nicht hörst,
keine Ahnung, so genau habe ich den Laden
da noch nicht verstanden, warum die das so machen.
Ne, nicht selbstprogrammiert.
Nicht selbstprogrammiert.
Die verwenden schon fertige Tools,
aber halt nicht die
Tools, die Google anbietet.
Weil, ich meine ernsthaft, warum
eigenes Monitoring Gedöns,
wenn Google das kann?
Warum eigenes Backup Zeug, wenn Google das kann?
Warum eigenes Secret Management, wenn Google das kann?
Das ist doch gerade der Vorteil davon,
wenn man eben so
bla bla bla as a Service benutzt,
oder halt Infrastructure
as a Service benutzt,
dass man eben auch die ergänzenden Cloud Services
drum herum benutzen kann, dass man sich eben nicht
um den Scheiß kümmern muss.
Wenn ich einfach nur nen Kubernetes Cluster
professioniere bei Google und nichts von dem
Google Ökosystem drum herum benutze gescheit,
da muss ich eigentlich auch
nicht Google
Cloud verwenden.
Also, zeig mal her, was ist denn hier jetzt die
Question?
Achso, Moment, ihr habt Checkmk benutzt,
um Metriken für PRTG
PRTG einzusammeln. Aha.
Okay, das hab ich noch nicht gesehen,
aber verstehe ich, ja. Ich gehe mal davon aus,
ihr seid recht Windows
heavy,
weil PRTG ist hauptsächlich im Windows
Umfeld
sehr beliebt.
Kann zwischen zwei Jobangeboten wählen,
IT Infrastructure
Architect, oh High IQ
Shit hier, jetzt geht's los.
Und IT Solution Engineer,
was klingt, es kommt drauf an, was die darunter verstehen.
Es kommt drauf an, was die
Unternehmen darunter verstehen.
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen. Erstens ist
Private Cloud, zweitens ist Public Cloud.
Ja, Private Cloud
ist die Frage, was sie unter Private Cloud
verstehen. Was, was wirklich bei euch
im Rechenzentrum steht, dann ist es ja im Prinzip
keine Cloud, außer wenn's cool klingt.
Oder, es ist bei irgendeinem
Cloud-Anbieter allerdings nicht Public
zugänglich. Letztendlich,
pff, keine Ahnung,
was sie darunter versteht. Also das kann
man pauschal nicht sagen. Anhand des Titels
kannst du nicht, kannst du nicht entscheiden,
was
besser ist. Ja.
Das kann beides nice sein, das kann auch beides
Müll sein. Das kann auch das eine gut
und das andere gut sein. Also,
da muss man, muss man mehr wissen,
das kann man so nicht, nicht,
richtig, richtig, genau das, so sieht's aus.
Ja. Also, also wenn
du die, falls du das leaken willst,
geh ich, ich vermute aber mal nicht,
kannst du die Stellenanzeigen mal schicken und wir können
reingucken. Aber so kann man das wirklich nicht sagen.
Oder du schreibst bisschen mehr Details, aber
ähm, pff, kann man,
kann man nicht wirklich viel,
Stich halte ich jetzt da zu sagen.
Das kann schon sein, teilweise, aber
nachdem die keine On-Prem Kubernetes
Sachen haben,
es macht keinen Sinn, es macht keinen Sinn Backup
selbst zu machen, wenn man
einfach das Google Cloud Backup für
Kubernetes Cluster verwenden kann.
Das geht halt einfach. Ich mach ein Häkchen
hin und es geht und ich kann das Restoren relativ
easy. Da muss ich mir keine Gedanken drüber
machen. Ja. Also falls
du, falls du Track, falls du schicken willst,
schick rüber.
Falls du überhaupt noch da bist.
Das nehme ich jetzt auch schon wieder 5 Minuten her.
Dann
können wir gucken. Verstehe nicht.
Tomox,
Dankeschön für den Sub. Massive
HIQ Subscript.
Prime
Subscriber. Ach 3, 2, 1
Backup. Das wäre
es damit eh nicht.
Morgen, welcher Cloud Provider hat dir
bis jetzt eigentlich am besten gefallen, Max?
Tja, da muss ich,
da muss ich tatsächlich ein bisschen ausholen. Es kommt auf
die Features an, die man braucht.
Also so für
Basics, VMs
erstellen, ja.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen, Hetzner. Hetzner hat
ein super nice, sehr schnelles
Web Interface. Kannst du auch per
Terraform benutzen und ist
an sich einfach saumäßig
schnell.
Ich kenn eigentlich nix, was günstig und, was so
günstig und schnell ist in Kombination wie Hetzner.
Und sich auch so gut benutzen lässt. Also
Usability, Geschwindigkeit,
Preis, muss ich sagen, Hetzner Cloud ist wirklich
top für mich. Auch wenn die mich aktuell nicht
sponsoren. Auch wenn ich irgendwie noch
einen Code hab, der nicht geht. Aber muss ich tatsächlich
sagen, ist nice. So.
Allerdings haben die halt fast nix
im Vergleich zu anderen Cloud
Anbietern. Die haben VMs. Das war's.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, Hetzner hat weder
Managed Datenbanken, noch Managed
Kubernetes, noch sonst irgendwas.
Ich glaub, das höchste der Gefühle, was Hetzner noch
zusätzlich hat, sind Managed
Loadbalancer. Ich glaub, das ist das einzige,
was es noch gibt. Du kriegst Managed
Loadbalancer und du kriegst
okay, Managed Firewall Regeln, aber
das würde jetzt nicht wirklich dazu zählen.
Ja, du kriegst, im Prinzip kriegst du
VMs und Loadbalancer bei Hetzner.
Das war's. Mehr gibt's da nicht.
Rest musst du dir selbst bauen. Wenn du
das kannst, ist es auch eine sehr gute Alternative.
Du kannst beispielsweise relativ easy,
gibt's schon vorgefertigte
Terraform-Packages oder auch
komplett vorgefertigte Scripts, was dir
Multinode-Cluster Kubernetes
aufbaut auf Hetzner. Ist dann auch relativ
günstig, weil halt Hetzner an sich relativ
günstig ist. Das kann man machen,
aber da muss man sich halt wirklich komplett selber drum
kümmern. Wobei
die Integration immer besser wird, ja.
Also auch, dass du, dass du Loadbalancer
benutzen kannst direkt aus deinem Cluster und so.
Also ist ganz okay.
So, also, wenn man
wirklich einfach nur VMs braucht
mit Public IP oder vielleicht
simple Web-Services laufen
lassen will, dann ist Hetzner Cloud wirklich nice.
Usability, Geschwindigkeit
und Preis. Ich finde, das ist eine super Kombination.
Das nächste ist, wenn man
ein bisschen mehr braucht, wenn man ein bisschen mehr
braucht, wenn man zum Beispiel Managed
Datenbank, Managed Kubernetes braucht, würde ich
mir tatsächlich mal DigitalOcean angucken.
DigitalOcean ist ganz nice.
Ups. Ah, Moment. Ich bin ja...
Ha.
Ich bin ja in Chattarino. Ich bin ja nicht mehr drin.
Ja. Ähm...
DigitalOcean kannst du
Datenbanken hosten, kannst du
Kubernetes hosten und es
ist auch relativ günstig
im Vergleich zu den großen Cloud-Anbietern.
Wenn die hier irgendwo
Pricing gescheit mal
stehen hätten... Ja, das ist
das Overall Pricing.
Hier, Kubernetes, letztendlich sind
Droplets sind bei denen VMs.
Databases geht los
ab 15 Euro im Monat. Und
wenn man es direkt vergleicht mit Amazon, ist es
tatsächlich eine ganze Ecke günstiger.
Was du kriegst an
CPU, RAM und Disk.
Und dann haben die Docs,
das ist DigitalOcean, also Managed Kubernetes
auf DigitalOcean.
Das ist auch deutlich günstiger als
zum Beispiel bei
Google oder bei
Amazon oder bei...
Wen habe ich vergessen? Microsoft.
Ich meine, guck mal, hier geht das Managed Kubernetes
ab 12 Euro im Monat los.
Ich glaube, bei Google bezahlst
du glaube ich so, wenn du es halbwegs gescheit konfigurierst,
so Minimum 70 Euro im Monat.
Und das ist schon kein Cluster, mit dem
du große Sprünge machen kannst.
Ja, das ist
das Nächste, die finde ich tatsächlich auch sehr nice.
Die gibt es übrigens auch schon deutlich
länger als
Google und Azure.
Ja, DigitalOcean ist schon relativ lang dabei.
Also wenn es ein bisschen mehr sein darf,
finde ich DigitalOcean nach wie vor ganz gut.
Hat auch den Vorteil im Vergleich zu manch anderen
Nischenanbietern, die
vielleicht auch nicht schlecht sind, dass
DigitalOcean nahezu überall auch supported wird.
Sei es jetzt in Terraform oder
irgendwelchen
DNS, Letzteren Club Zertifikat
Tools und solche Geschichten. Also
DigitalOcean ist auch überall dabei. Tja, und ansonsten
bleiben jetzt ja eigentlich nur die großen
drei übrig.
Also Azure,
Google Cloud Platform und AWS
Amazon. Gut, theoretisch
gibt es ja noch ein paar andere. IBM
hat auch eine Cloud, Oracle hat auch eine Cloud,
aber seriously, die habe ich beide noch nicht benutzt.
Die eins, warum
ich wollte mir mal einen Oracle
Cloud Account machen
und da musste man aber Kreditkarte und
Handy und alles mögliche eintragen, da hatte ich
keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Also im Prinzip bleibt
AKS, äh nicht AKS,
AWS,
AKS ist Managed Kubernetes
auf Azure. Azure,
AWS und GCP übrig.
Und wer gefällt mir davon am besten?
Es ist nicht so,
das hätte ich alle gleich am meisten verwendet.
Also AWS habe ich bisher am wenigsten verwendet.
Azure habe ich insgesamt am meisten
verwendet. In letzter Zeit am meisten
habe ich GCP verwendet.
Ich würde sagen, die nehmen sich alle
nicht sonderlich viel. AWS
ist gefühlt
das Oldschooligste. Ich glaube, die waren auch
mit am ersten am Start.
Bei AWS habe ich das Problem, dass ich
immer nicht weiß, wie die Sachen heißen.
AWS ist Marktführer.
Ich glaube schon,
ich bin mir aber nicht sicher.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Also ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Also AWS habe ich immer das Problem,
dass ich nicht weiß, wie der ganze Krempel
heißt, weil wie gesagt, das eine heißt
Fargate, äh
Route 53
und solche Geschichten. Also die Dinger,
die heißen halt alle so, dass man sich
nicht vorstellen kann, was damit gemeint
ist. Aber okay, ich glaube, wenn man in diesem
AWS Ökosystem unterwegs ist, blickt
man da relativ gut durch. Ansonsten fand ich
das Webinterface von AWS,
sehr Oldschool, sieht ein bisschen aus wie Amazon
Amazon Webshop.
Aber ganz okay.
Azure ist das, wo
ich tatsächlich noch am ehesten den
Durchblick habe, wo was ist.
Ich persönlich finde auch das Azure Webinterface
am besten.
Es ist echt
ein sehr subjektiver Eindruck, ja.
Das Azure Webinterface
wirkt für mich am
am freundlichsten.
Das ist bescheuert. Ich meine, es ist egal, ob ein Cloud Interface
freundlich wirkt oder nicht. Aber das Azure Webinterface,
wirkt schön designt,
ja. Also es ist zwar auch wir,
wo was ist, 100.000 Untermenüs
und seitliche
Side-Menüs, die aufklappen. Aber ich
finde, das wirkt freundlich, das
Azure Webinterface. Von den Icons,
die anderen verwenden kaum bunte Icons,
ja. Wobei AWS weiß
ich nicht so genau.
Also von den Icons, von der Schriftart,
von der Aufmachung her, gefällt mir
das Webinterface von Azure bisher am besten.
Allerdings ist, wo was
steht in Azure auch serviert.
Da muss ich sagen, da finde ich Google tatsächlich
bis jetzt ganz gut. Die haben zwar auch
30 Millionen Services.
Wir können uns einfach mal einloggen.
Ja.
Die haben zwar 30 Millionen Services
bei Google. Sekunde
Flashbang. Wir machen's
mal kurz in Chrome auf.
Aber ein besseres, besseres Dark Theme.
So. Also.
Da muss man sagen, bei Google,
also die ganze Google Cloud Geschichte,
die haben das auch ganz
gut gemacht. Die haben nicht so viele krasse Untermenüs.
Die haben eher so Oldschool,
Oldschool Dropdown-Geschichten.
Aber das meiste ist echt sinnvoll
benannt. Ich bin, ich würde fast
sagen, Google hat die beste Benahmung
von ihren Services, von den drei großen
Sachen. Also
unter Compute Engine, guck mal.
Virtual Machines, da kann man sich
sofort was darunter vorstellen. Ja.
Kubernetes Engine kann man sich auch was sofort darunter vorstellen.
SQL-Daten kann man sich auch was darunter
vorstellen. Cloud Storage
kann man sich auch ein bisschen sofort was darunter vorstellen.
Network kann man sich auch was, also man weiß
eigentlich relativ schnell, wo
man hin muss. Gut. Cloud Run
ist ein bisschen, muss man wissen, was es ist.
Sonst, sonst kann man damit nichts anfangen.
Cloud Run ist quasi
Container
laufen lassen, Container as a Service
laufen lassen. Also sprich, man braucht kein
Kubernetes oder irgendwas anderes. Man gibt ein
Container Image an und lässt das Ding laufen. Und gut,
das ist die einfachste Variante,
hier bei Google Container Images
laufen zu lassen. BigQuery ist glaube ich
die, warum das nicht
hier drunter ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich vermute
mal, weil BigQuery eben die
NoSQL-Datenbank ist. Deswegen
wäre es ein bisschen blöd unter SQL, dass,
ich meine, die hätten es auch einfach Database nennen können
und dann Cloud SQL und
BigQuery da drunter schreiben. Also BigQuery
ist glaube ich das NoSQL von Google,
wenn ich das jetzt nicht durcheinander
bringe. Und
SQL ist halt Managed Postgres,
Managed MySQL oder
Managed Microsoft SQL.
Cringe.
Falls irgendjemand wirklich Managed MySQL
betreiben will, guckt hier.
Nein, nein, nicht Cloud Run.
SQL kannst du hier auswählen,
Create Instance, MySQL,
Postgres, Postgres
und SQL Server, Alter.
NO GOD!
Also mir ist nicht klar, warum das jemand machen will.
Aber okay,
gibt bestimmt Leute,
die brauchen unbedingt ein SQL Server.
Ansonsten ist das Zeug wirklich ganz
gut benannt. Du findest alles,
also wenn man sich da ein bisschen dran gewöhnt hat,
ist es wirklich nice. Hier hast du deine ganzen
Rechnungsschitt. Hier kannst du Monitoring,
AP Access und sowas einschalten.
Marketplace habe ich noch nie verwendet. Und hier kannst du
irgendwelche Berechtigungen, User und solche Zeug
anlegen. Ist eigentlich ganz gut gemacht.
Aber
das ist natürlich nicht alles.
Die haben natürlich noch viel mehr.
Und spätestens, wenn man diesen anderen Krempel
hier einblendet. Ja.
Da wird's halt, da wird's halt ein bissl
bissl mehr.
Elastic Cloud, das ist Amazon, oder?
Distributed Cloud.
Keine Ahnung, was das hier alles ist.
Es gibt noch viel mehr. Da ist es dann schon
wieder etwas
unübersichtlich,
was die hier alles
bieten.
Healthcare, Luca, man hat
man hat keine Ahnung, IoT,
die haben einen Managed MQTT Service.
Pubs, okay, da kann man, das ist
die Message Queue von denen. Da wird's dann
tatsächlich schon ein bisschen unübersichtlicher.
Das heißt, solange man sich hier
nur in den,
in dem oberen Teil bewegt,
finde ich, ist Google Cloud wirklich schön
und übersichtlich.
Danach hört's dann aber auch auf.
Aber man kommt, das meiste, was
man braucht, ist aber tatsächlich hier drüber.
Mehr braucht man normalerweise auch gar nicht.
Ja.
Ich denke, jetzt habe ich das ausführlich genug
beantwortet. Also,
ich habe beantwortet, dass ich es nicht richtig
beantworten kann, glaube ich. Ja.
Was ist eigentlich
der Lieblings-Webserver unter Linux?
Tja, kommt auch drauf an.
Defaultmäßig, wenn ich sonst keine Ahnung habe,
was ich damit machen will, Nginx,
für Let's Encrypt,
wenn es besonders easy sein soll, Cudi.
Cudi ist nice, wenn man,
wenn man Let's Encrypt braucht, entweder auf einem
Public,
auf, wenn man auf einem Public Server,
also mit Public IP Let's Encrypt braucht
und da ein bisschen Reverse Proximal.
Da ist Cudi nice. Für alles andere würde ich Nginx
benutzen.
Traffic mag ich gar nicht.
Ich weiß, viele mögen Traffic und auch
im Container, gerade so in diese,
viele Leute, die daheim
Docker Compose Files haben und sowas, die machen das gerne
mit Traffic.
Muss ich persönlich sagen, Traffic
ist mir zu weirdchamp
zu konfigurieren, solange es nicht
autodiscovern kann, was man haben will.
Ist nicht meine erste Wahl.
Also ist entweder Nginx, auch im Kubernetes
Umfeld Nginx.
Übrigens, da ist auch, wisst ihr,
es ist schon ein bisschen Painschamp, die Benahmung.
Guckt mal, Leute. Es gibt Nginx,
es gibt für Kubernetes Nginx,
Nginx Ingress
und es gibt
Moment mal.
Es gibt Ingress Nginx
und es gibt Nginx Ingress.
Wer jetzt denkt,
dass das das gleiche ist,
der täuscht sich.
Nginx Ingress und Ingress Nginx
ist nicht das gleiche.
Warum man es so beschissen benannt hat, ich weiß
es nicht. Der Unterschied ist,
also es sind beides,
also es ist beides ein
Ingress Webserver für
Kubernetes, aber
Ingress Nginx
ist der offizielle Ingress
von Kubernetes selbst,
der halt auf Nginx
basiert und Nginx
Ingress ist der offizielle
Ingress Controller von Nginx.
Also das Ding wird von den Nginx
von der Nginx Firma erstellt
und das Ding wird vom
Kubernetes Team erstellt.
Beides basiert auf Nginx, aber es sind zwei
unterschiedliche Sachen.
Also in der Regel verwendet
man eigentlich den hier.
Warum man den anderen benutzen sollte,
weiß ich nicht.
I don't know.
Was ist, genau habe ich beantwortet.
Was ist mit
ist
das Scam, wenn ich das hier anklicke, Leute?
Kann ich das anklicken?
Ohne dass was schlimmes passiert?
Okay, ja.
Kenn ich nicht.
Habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Secure in the Cloud with Nodes.
Ist das ein Witz
für Node?
Nodes?
Oder was wollen
die mir damit sagen?
No Eats?
Ist es nicht einfach?
Okay, was auch immer das bedeuten soll.
Kenn ich nicht.
Aber das sieht jetzt nicht nach einem
Cloud Anbieter aus, sondern
nach irgendeinem komischen
VPN Anbieter.
Also ganz
ehrlich würde ich nicht hingehen.
VPN Anbieter haben immer für mich so einen shady
Beigeschmack.
Also man kann sich Linux Server
mieten.
Ansonsten sehe ich jetzt auch keine weiteren Services.
Also das ist, scheint mir
mehr oder weniger
ein ganz normaler
VM Hosting Anbieter
zu sein. Also weder Managed
Datenbanken noch Managed Kubernetes
oder sonst was.
Also im Prinzip eher was Richtung
Google Cloud.
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Aber allein schon, weil die VPN haben.
Weiß ich nicht.
Komisch Zeug.
Also wie gesagt, mein Default Web Server
ist eigentlich immer Nginx.
Außer es ist Kadi, wenn man es an der Stelle
gerade braucht. Ansonsten eigentlich immer.
Im Kubernetes Umfeld Nginx und
ansonsten auch Nginx.
Oder Kadi ab und zu.
Macht man bei Google Cloud eigentlich auch so Sachen
wie Projekte jeweils in eigene Accounts abstrahieren?
Ja, ja, ja.
Schon sinnig.
Eigene Accounts nicht, Projekte in eigene
Projekte und
Google Cloud ist umgedreht. Du legst Accounts
in Projekten an und nicht
Projekte in Accounts.
Also du legst ein Projekt an
und in diesem Projekt legst du dann Accounts an
mit unterschiedlichen Berechtigungen.
Du kannst
Projekte nesten
und vererben lassen. Da muss ich ehrlich sagen,
das habe ich aber noch selbst noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das geht. Also du kannst Unterprojekte
anlegen.
Oh, wieder am Start.
Patrick auch da.
Jetzt wird es voll hier.
Ja, also ich glaube auch, würde
ich auch so pauschal sagen,
wenn jemand sich
ein bisschen Cloud Infrastruktur anguckt
und
so den Einstieg
machen will,
ich würde tatsächlich sagen, Azure ist zum
Einstieg das angenehmste.
Wobei ich Google Cloud auch nicht
übel finde. Google Cloud kann tatsächlich
sogar ganz gut sein für euch, weil ihr habt
bestimmt schon einen Google Account.
Google Account könnt ihr einfach die Trial machen.
Loggt euch in der
Konsole ein und
startet die Trial. Und wenn ihr eh schon
Handynummer und alles bei eurem Google Account überlegt habt,
könnt ihr die Trial wahrscheinlich auch direkt starten.
Und dann
macht ihr GCP Trial
und könnt es ausprobieren. Also
Azure hat glaube ich 200 Dollar
Startguthaben und Google
hat 300 Dollar Startguthaben.
AWS weiß ich nicht.
AWS Trial, was ist was die haben?
Kostenlose, ja Moment.
12 Monate kostenlos.
Also AWS hat
anscheinend auch sowas. Aber
keine Ahnung. Also im Prinzip
ist es egal zu welcher Cloud Plattform ihr
geht. Aber so
Bauchgefühl sagt mir auch, dass wenn man
ganz frisch einsteigt, Azure
zumindest vom UI und den Sachen
drumherum den angenehmeren
Einstieg hat.
Schwer zu sagen.
Also wahrscheinlich ist es bei jedem individuell
ein bisschen anders.
Ich würde schon sagen Azure, tatsächlich.
IES, ja bester Webserver
eindeutig.
HA-Proxy ist mein Go-To, Reverse-Proxy, Keep-Alive.
Ja okay, wenn man
sowas selbst machen will,
also wenn man selbst
einen hochverfügbaren
Loadbalancer bauen möchte, dann
ja, dann verstehe ich das mit HA-Proxy.
Wenn man jetzt allerdings beispielsweise
den fertigen Ingress-Controller
von Google verwendet und sowas, dann braucht man
das Ganze nicht mehr selbst bauen.
Ich glaube, hatten wir nicht mal geguckt,
basierte der Hetzner
Loadbalancer nicht auch auf Nginx?
Ne, auf HA-Proxy, gell?
War das nicht sogar ein HA-Proxy?
Hatten wir nicht mal nachgeguckt?
Ich glaube, der Hetzner
Loadbalancer basierte auch auf HA-Proxy.
Aber HA-Proxy ist auch
ein gutes Projekt, kann man auch verwenden.
Muss ein bisschen gucken,
was man macht. Ja, Traffic mag ich
nicht. Außerdem ist die Performance von Traffic
im Vergleich zu allen anderen ziemlicher Müll.
Die haben
ein 1 Euro pro Monat Angebot.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
1 Euro im Monat.
Ja, Moment, wenn ich mich zweijährlich
festlege. Ne, wobei,
auch so, ja, ungefähr.
Ich will kein Premium VPN. Was bekommt man denn?
Ein CPU-Core, 256 MB RAM,
Debian Standard,
Traffic...
Ohne Scheiß,
für einen Euro im Monat ist wahrscheinlich,
wenn man eine Public-IP-Adresse braucht,
ist wahrscheinlich für einen Euro im Monat
gar kein schlechtes Angebot.
Ne?
Ja...
Wenn der Snapshot doppelt so viel wie die 4M kostet,
Keckel, Alter. Guck mal.
Ja...
Es ist preislich tatsächlich
ganz gut.
Es wird halt schon ziemlich teuer,
gell? Mal gucken, monatlich.
Ähm...
Lass uns mal kurz mit Hetzner vergleichen.
Okay, ist ungefähr
mehr oder weniger der gleiche Preis.
Hetzner Cloud Pricing.
Ein Ticken billiger.
Prices.
Die Triple-Core-Kiste.
Die Gigabyte RAM 898
mit Public-IP.
Ohne Papier...
Ja, okay, okay.
Also, man ist hier tatsächlich ein Ticken
günstiger als bei Hetzner. Wobei bei Hetzner
der Traffic deutlich großzügiger ist.
Hier.
Also wirklich deutlich großzügiger
der Traffic.
Und auch deutlich mehr Disk-Space.
Das heißt, wenn man hier mal was ähnliches
einstellt. Weil Hetzner ist tatsächlich
relativ großzügig mit 80
Gigabyte Disk-Space.
Da kostet es mehr oder weniger genau das gleiche.
Und mit Traffic
kostet es sogar noch mehr. Also
sind wir wieder beim ursprünglichen Punkt.
Man muss halt wissen, was man braucht.
Und
dann
kann man sich auch das Billigste raussuchen.
Ist richtiger Schmutz. Siehste?
Ich bin schon... Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Chat. Ich will das jetzt nicht so unkommentiert
lassen, weil ich keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Ich will es ja auch einfach nur den Anbieter schlecht machen.
Ich hab ihn noch nicht benutzt. Aber ich
finde es schon ein bisschen... Also alles, was
VPN anbietet, ist für mich so ein bisschen
shady irgendwie.
Hetzner bietet indirekt auch VPN an.
Aber sie sagen, du kannst hier
einen virtuellen Server mieten und dann
One-Click einen VPN drauf installieren. Die bieten kein
explizites VPN an. Was ich persönlich
die viel bessere Variante
finde. Exoscale.
Können wir mal kurz reingucken.
Auf einmal hat der Ultra Owner
69 HD Quickscope 2
VMs. Ja, kann doch sein.
Ist ja nicht schlimm. Vielleicht ist er richtig
krasser Cloud Native
Solutions Architekt, der
Ultra Owner 69.
Ja, man muss eine Kreditkarte hinterlegen.
Falls du auf die Idee
kommst, mit irgendeiner
Einweg-Kreditkarten-
generierungs-App das zu machen,
musst du Glück haben, dass es
funktioniert. Bei mir hat es funktioniert. Allerdings
hat der Google Support dann gesagt... Also ne,
das stimmt nicht. Umgedreht. Bei mir hat es
funktioniert. Ich konnte mir den Account anlegen. Ich konnte
die Kreditkarte hinterlegen. Aber Google Cloud
hat dann gesagt,
sie können ihren Account nicht benutzen und der
Support wird sich das innerhalb der nächsten 48 Stunden
angucken. Und dann habe ich die normale
Kreditkarte hinterlegt und dann ging es so fort.
Wenn du selbst privat dir
was angucken willst. Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Also bei Google Cloud ist es wirklich nicht
schlimm, die Kreditkarte zu hinterlegen, weil
du musst explizit
deinen Account upgraden, dass es
was abrechnet.
Also du kannst zwar
deine Kreditkarte hinterlegen, aber selbst wenn du
über den Trial-Zeitraum hinaus
Ressourcen hast, werden die
nicht abgerechnet, sondern einfach nur
gelöscht. Ja, dann gucken wir nochmal
kurz rein. Wenn der Chat sagt, ich soll
mal Exoscale angucken, gucken wir uns mal Exoscale an.
Ok, die Webseite blendet
mich wenigstens nicht sofort.
Solid European Cloud Hosting
Alternative. Was haben die denn schönes?
Managed Datenbanken,
Managed Komponente. Ok, oh guck
mal, die haben GPU-Servers.
Ist da Sirius Max da?
Das wär doch was, oder?
Wär das nicht
was fürs Archiv?
Wär das nicht was fürs Archiv?
GPU-Server? Brauchen wir da nicht
GPU-Server?
Oder hatten wir nicht bei denen
sogar GPU-Server?
Irgendwo hatten wir doch GPU-Server.
Ok, lass mal kurz gucken.
Discover our GPU-Products.
Da bin ich mir noch nicht mal sicher, ob
alle großen Cloud-Anbieter GPU,
GPU-VMs mittlerweile haben.
Also Google hat, bei den anderen bin ich mir gar nicht
so sicher.
So, was haben die denn hier?
GPU-Products.
Our Tesla P-
Our Tesla V-
Guck mal, hier gibt's ein A40
Das ist die ganz fette Kiste.
In G-Cloud sah man auch
Preise in der Oberfläche, das machen andere nicht.
Das stimmt, bei Microsoft gibt es
einen extra Calculator dafür. Ich vermute mal
AWS auch. Wobei
Google es auch nur
ungefähr Werte sind.
Check out GPU-Pricing.
Zeig mal her, was kostet
es denn? Alter, richtig
fette Kiste.
12 Cores, eine GPU,
800 GSSD,
kostet 1,01 Euro.
Oh, das ist teuer.
Das sind ja irgendwie 30 Euro am Tag.
Das ist teuer.
Also, wenn man den Monat
haben will, bezahlt man 840 Euro.
Auf der anderen Seite,
hier sieht man einen großen Vorteil
von Cloud-Architektur.
Du brauchst diesen Server ja wahrscheinlich
gar keinen Monat lang.
Du brauchst diesen Server vielleicht
3-4 Stunden, je nachdem, was du machen willst.
Je nachdem, was du machen willst.
Kommt immer drauf an.
Du brauchst diesen Server ja vielleicht nur 2-3 Stunden.
Und dann ist das preislich sehr attraktiv.
Du bezahlst am Ende 5 Euro
für ein paar Stunden
und hast eine fette Cloud-Kiste,
die fetter ist, als was du bei dir daheim stehen hast.
Sogar in der Basic-Ausstattung wahrscheinlich schon.
Und hast eine GPU drinnen.
Und wenn du was richtig, richtig Fettes brauchst,
nimmst du die mit 4 GPUs drin,
bezahlst ungefähr 3 Euro die Stunde,
aber mal angenommen, mal ohne Scheiß,
wenn du in, sagen wir mal,
du bist in 4-5 Stunden durch,
ist das immer noch umwelten besser,
als dir selbst so was anzuschaffen.
Ich meine, so eine Kiste dir anzuschaffen,
da bist du mal 10.000 Euro los.
Gut, ich weiß nicht, welche GPUs sind,
ich weiß nicht, wie teuer die Dinger sind,
aber würde ich jetzt einfach mal schätzen,
dass du da ungefähr 10.000 Euro Hardwareinvestition hast.
Und...
Hier kriegst du es halt für
10 Euro für ein paar Stunden.
Also, da sieht man, dass sich
Cloud-Sachen wirklich lohnen können,
auch preislich, wenn man
eben solche Burst-Szenarien hat.
Also, ich brauch mal schnell
ganz viel Rechenleistung, aber in 4 Stunden
bin ich durch und brauch sie nicht mehr.
Das ist wirklich gut.
Das geht natürlich noch deutlich teurer, vermute ich mal.
GPU 2 Instances,
yep, kostet nochmal eine ganze Ecke mehr.
Und GPU 3...
So...
Also...
17 Euro die Stunde.
Alter!
Da geht es jetzt langsam wirklich ins Geld an.
17 Euro die Stunde.
Okay, das ist wirklich ordentlich.
17 mal 24
mal 30.
Das kostet nicht nur 12.000 Euro
im Monat. Ohne Scheiß,
das ist immer noch billiger,
das Ding im Monat in der Cloud zu betreiben.
so ein Ding zu kaufen, ja?
Stell dir vor, du vergisst die auszuschalten,
ja?
Ja, das ist schon ordentlich, aber das ist,
das ist tatsächlich, das ist tatsächlich mal eine
echt fette Kiste.
Sirius Max, was meinst du, wie viele Stunden
braucht das Archiv zum,
zum Voice-Extrahieren mit so einer Kiste?
Wobei, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob wir
überhaupt, ob das, ob das überhaupt
auf A40-GPU-Dingern
gescheit läuft.
Ja, ich denke schon, dass das
1-2 Tage braucht, das komplette Archiv,
auch auf den fetten Kisten, oder?
Ich denke, das letzte lief, glaube ich,
zwei Wochen?
Wie, wie lang lief der, oder eine Woche?
Wie lang lief der letzte Archiv,
äh, Komplettlauf?
Eine Woche?
Das lief schon ein paar Tage, ja?
Additional Services, okay, man kann sich das
richtig, richtig fett zusammenbauen hier.
Das fällt
auch nicht mehr, das fällt auch nicht mehr
ins Gewicht, oder? Eine Windows-Lizenz.
Bei dem, bei den Preisen.
Die komplette, das letzte,
lief zwei Wochen.
Also, aber
finde ich gut, finde ich, finde ich, finde ich wirklich
sehr, sehr nice.
Ähm, so, was haben sie sonst
noch zu bieten? Pricing.
Also, ja, guck mal, lass uns mal
kurz Pricing durchgucken. Ich finde es tatsächlich ganz
interessant. Also, Compute,
Standard Instances, was haben die hier?
Kann man das nicht vielleicht mal auf Monat
umschalten? So muss ich immer selbst rechnen,
das ist doch doof.
Haben die irgendwo einen Schalter, um das auf Monat umzuschalten?
Okay, Vergleich,
reichen wir mal die
Triple Core,
das, okay,
mal 24, mal
30,
67.
Da ist eine Hetzner-VM halt deutlich günstiger.
Kostet halt, kostet halt
trotzdem 67 Euro,
67 Euro im Monat.
Das ist,
das ist nicht, das ist echt,
äh,
ganz schön teuer. Habe ich mir jetzt irgendwie
verrechnet?
Nee, oder?
Ja, Monat?
Stundenpreis mal 24 mal 30.
67 Euro.
Quickmuffs, aber
das ist schon ganz schön teuer.
Bei Hetzner bezahle ich da
20 oder so?
Ja.
Bei Hetzner bezahle ich da 16 und 20 Euro.
Oh, das lohnt sich jetzt tatsächlich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn man,
wenn man mehr braucht
und wenn man GPU-Instances braucht,
macht das einen guten Eindruck.
Was kostet denn, was kostet
Managed Postgres?
Okay, Managed Postgres,
2 GB RAM,
8 GB Platz,
maximal 25 Connections.
Okay, da kommt man, da kommt man nicht wirklich so weit mit.
Wobei das,
wobei das für kleine Anwendungen durchaus geht.
Ich meine, es
ist ja nicht pro User eine Connection,
sondern pro Backend-Service
dann wahrscheinlich eine Connection. Oder je nachdem,
wie viel man konfiguriert hat.
Ja, das dürften ungefähr die Preise,
ähnliche, das dürften ähnliche Preise sein
zu den, zu den VMs.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Das ist, das ist quasi die VM-Preise plus ein plus
Managed, Managed Datenbank-Gebühr.
Aber es ist auch nicht billig.
Es ist wirklich nicht billig.
Ja, 193 Euro für eine Managed Datenbank geht schon ein bisschen was.
Gut, der Vorteil von Managed Datenbanken ist halt einfach,
man muss sich selbst nicht um High Availability und sonstige Geschichten kümmern.
Äh, Fly, Fly,
AIO ist zurzeit auf, äh, in Cloud-Kreisen total angesagt.
So, also preislich würde ich sagen,
ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt das, wo ich sofort hinrennen würde,
aber scheint mir ganz okay zu sein.
Jo. Lass uns mal ganz kurz Managed Kubernetes gucken,
was das kostet bei denen.
Da gucken wir auch ein paar Videos.
Wir sind schon, ich bin eine Stunde am labern.
Hallo?
Äh, Pricing?
Pricing?
Äh, ist das?
Äh, SKS?
Warum müssen die das alle abkürzen mit irgendeinem Mist?
ProCluster.
Das ist relativ günstig.
Das ist tatsächlich, es ist nicht so günstig wie DigitalOcean,
aber das ist relativ günstig,
wenn man das vergleicht mit, äh, Google und, und, ähm, AWS.
Gut, weiß man ja nicht, was drinnen steckt.
Das ist tatsächlich relativ günstig dann.
Okay.
Pricing, was kostet's hier?
Kommen da die Nodes hinzu?
Das hat, stimmt, das hätten wir, müssen wir sich mal genau angucken.
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht geguckt, was drinnen ist.
Die sind, die sind halt nochmal eine ganze Ecke billiger hier, Fly.io.
Guck mal, 1,94 im Monat, Shared CPU, ansonsten gibt's natürlich auch, die haben glaube ich
keine GPU, die haben keine GPU Instances, aber die haben glaube ich Data, Database,
Databases and Storage, ja, die sind gerade recht beliebt, wenn man so den, bei den einschlägigen
Subreddits, wo es um Cloud-Technologien geht, unterwegs ist, ist Fly.io zurzeit recht beliebt.
Ich habe es selbst noch nicht benutzt.
Leider braucht man auch Kreditkarte und alles wieder.
Ja, so sieht's aus, so, genug Cloud-Campel.
Vergleich das mal hiermit.
Okay.
Ach, hier hast du das Archiv, hier hast du das Archiv-Dings.
Einmal ATX.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, mit was sich das vergleichen lässt.
Dürfte, dürfte, dürfte auch relativ, ähm, ja, ist ein bisschen, ist ein bisschen günstiger
als Exoscale, würde ich jetzt mal so auf den ersten Blick sagen.
Okay.
Wait a minute, der Sbarro ist da?
Wo ist er?
Habe ich ihn gar nicht gesehen?
Wo ist er denn?
Habe ich etwa den einzig wahren Mod übersehen?
Ne, der ist gar nicht da.
Der ist gar nicht da.
Debated.
Äh, wie hast du eigentlich bei E3 die JetBrains-Toolbox oben rechts hinbekommen?
Äh, du meinst das da?
Das ist ganz normal die E3-Tray-Area.
Kann man hier konfigurieren?
Guck.
Tray-Output-Primary.
Ähm, mehr musst du, ich glaube, mehr musst du gar nicht machen, als das hier einstellen.
Ich glaube, du musst einfach sagen, Tray-Output, also auf welchem Bildschirm.
Und ich glaube, das war's.
Okay.
Und dann gehen die Icons automatisch halt da oben hin?
Jo.
So, jetzt lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Komm, wir müssen uns mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen zeigen.
Aufwachen-Stream.
Und ich Cloud-Native-Solution-Chief-Architect-Officer-Stream.
Weil, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, was ist das Video vom Tim jetzt?
Okay, wo habe ich das überhaupt?
Von hinten mal gucken.
Wo ist es, Chat?
Irgendwo?
Das da meinst du?
Meinst du das?
Wie deine erste Programmiersprache über deinen Erfolg entscheidet?
Oder welches Video meinst du, sollten wir uns angucken von ihm?
Nee?
Okay.
Sondern?
Ach doch.
Okay.
Darkside, weil du es bist.
Gucken wir uns das jetzt an.
Okay.
Wie deine erste, wie deine erste Programmiersprache über deinen Erfolg entscheidet.
... Softwareentwickler.
Und als ich damals beim Informatikstudium angefangen habe, stand ich vor derselben Herausforderung wie jeder andere auch.
Da fehlt die beste Programmiersprache schon mal dabei.
Die kannst du schon mal weglassen.
Und JavaScript, ja okay, ist zum Einstieg tatsächlich, finde ich, die beste.
Ohne Mist, ich bin der Meinung, JavaScript ist zum Einstieg die beste Sprache.
Liegt daran, liegt daran, habe ich glaube ich auch im Video damals mit Florian erzählt,
liegt daran, dass du keinerlei Einstiegs- oder wenig, eine sehr geringe Einstiegshürde hast.
Um mit JavaScript anzufangen, brauchst du einen Texteditor und einen Browser.
Das hat jeder daheim.
Und du siehst halt gleich, wenn du irgendwelche Webseiten ein bisschen rumbastelst, siehst du auch gleich, was passiert.
Also ich persönlich finde JavaScript tatsächlich am besten zum Einstieg.
Sprache wähle ich denn jetzt eigentlich aus?
Anfangs dachte ich, dass das total egal ist.
Wieso die Entscheidung aber deutlich wichtiger ist, als du vielleicht im ersten Moment denkst.
Und wie du die Antwort darauf mit einer einzelnen, simplen Frage bekommen kannst, welche Programmiersprache richtig für dich ist,
das erkläre ich dir hier in diesem Video.
Programmieren ist weiterhin einer der gefragtesten Fähigkeiten auf dem Markt.
Und als Anfänger kann es dann doch sehr überfordernd sein, wirklich einer der tausenden Programmiersprachen zu lernen.
Und dann stellt sich auch immer noch die Frage, welche denn eigentlich?
Als ich dann 2017, zu Anfang meines Studiums, in den Räumen meiner Hochschule saß,
dachte ich mir auch, es ist erstmal total egal, welche Programmiersprache ich da eigentlich lerne.
Ehrlicherweise hatte ich mich auch ein bisschen gelähmt gefühlt von den ganzen Auswahlmöglichkeiten und dachte, mich jetzt schon festzulegen, das kann doch nur schief gehen.
In gewisser Weise stimme ich dazu, wenn es um die Basics geht, wie irgendwelche Bedingungen, Schleifen oder Variablen und, und, und.
Dann ist es wirklich egal, mit welcher Programmiersprache du das lernst.
Aber das Ziel sollte ja sein, nicht nur einfach die Basics zu lernen, sondern langfristig dran zu bleiben und auch noch...
Wichtig ist vor allem, dass man nicht mit so einem Mist anfängt, wie if-Schleife.
Wenn ich das höre, kriege ich ein bisschen Angst.
Wenn ich das höre, kriege ich immer Anfälle.
Wenn mir einer anfängt mit if-Schleife...
... Spaß am Programmieren zu haben.
Ich sage ja immer wieder, Programmieren lernst du nur durchs Programmieren und am besten dann auch noch, wenn du es in Projekten umsetzt.
Aber wenn du es in Projekten umsetzen willst, dann sollten es auch welche sein, die dir selbst Spaß machen.
Mir ging es damals so, als ich in der Hochschule auf der Arbeit Java gelernt habe, dass die Sachen, die ich da umsetze...
Ja, ja, ja, Java. Ja, kein Wunder.
Da hätte ich auch keinen Bock mehr gehabt, weiter zu programmieren.
Java zum Einstieg. Ich weiß, viele machen Java zum Einstieg.
Gerade weil viele Professoren an der Uni oder Referenten an der Uni dann Java machen.
... sollte mir nicht unbedingt so viel Spaß gemacht haben.
Deswegen ist es meiner Meinung nach auch so wichtig, dass du am Anfang die richtige Programmiersprache für dich auswählst.
Lernst du also am Anfang eine Programmiersprache, mit der du deine Projekte und deine Vorstellungen vor allem gar nicht so einfach umsetzen kannst,
dann ist es sehr schnell sehr überfordernd, bringt gar keinen Spaß und das Programmieren wird wieder links liegen gelassen und man kommt gar nicht erst richtig rein.
Wenn du dann auch...
Wenn du als Anfänger dauerhaft die Programmiersprache wechselst, dann bist du letztendlich gar nicht dabei, irgendwie programmieren zu lernen,
sondern einfach nur die verschiedenen Syntax von den verschiedenen Programmiersprachen.
Das stimmt wohl.
Und dann erstellst du auch nicht wirklich irgendwas...
Dafür, es ist nicht verkehrt, also wenn man ein bisschen Ahnung hat, ist es echt nicht verkehrt, sich unterschiedliche Sprachen anzugucken.
Einfach, dass man mal sieht, wie manche Probleme andere Sprachen lösen und man auch so ein bisschen die Vor- und Nachteile sieht.
Lange Zeit ging mir bei Go zum Beispiel extrem auf den Sack, dass es keine Generics...
Gibt es jetzt, aber sie sind ziemlich müllig implementiert, wie ich finde.
Ja.
Was dir Spaß macht oder dich erfüllt, na gut, vielleicht macht dir Syntax-Lernen Spaß, mich persönlich könntest du damit jagen.
Und deswegen finde ich es auch so wichtig, dich am Anfang vor allem auf eine einzelne Programmiersprache zu spezialisieren.
Entscheide dich auch für qualitativ hochwertigen Content auf YouTube und abonniere meinen Kanal.
Toll, jetzt soll ich mich für eine Programmiersprache entscheiden?
Du gibst mir überhaupt gar keine Hilfestellung, welche denn oder was ich denn da machen soll.
Das gibt doch sofort ein Dislike.
Ich kann dir jetzt, na klar, die Standardantwort geben und irgendwie sagen...
Ja, fang mit JavaScript an. Das ist die Standardantwort von mir.
Soll es JavaScript, Python oder vielleicht Java...
Nein, JavaScript.
Und na klar, Python mit der einfachen Syntax lässt sich vielleicht einfacher lesen und einfacher verstehen für Anfänger.
Aber es ist dann auch die richtige Programmiersprache für dich.
Das kannst du dann auch mit einer einzigen leichten Frage beantworten.
Doch die Antwort ist...
Okay, Leute.
Wollen wir wetten?
Nein.
Ich...
Ich versuche mich mal jetzt im Gedankenlesen so, ja, von dem, was er sich dabei gedacht hat.
Wollen wir wetten?
Hier aus diesem Part hat er ein YouTube-Short gemacht.
Auch die richtige Programmiersprache für dich.
Das kann...
Weil es ist ein Schnitt und es ist Text unten drunter.
Es sieht eins zu eins aus wie YouTube-Shorts.
Ich wette mit euch, er hat exakt von diesem Ausschnitt ein YouTube-Shorts gemacht.
Gucken wir gleich mal.
Das kannst du dann auch mit einer einzigen leichten Frage beantworten.
Doch die Antwort ist sehr individuell.
Und deswegen kann ich sie nicht für dich beantworten.
Ich kam dann sehr schnell auf die Antwort, dass nicht Java meine Programmiersprache der Wahl ist,
sondern lieber JavaScript.
Ha!
Wisst du?
Sag ich doch JavaScript.
Wenn ich Java gewählt wäre, wäre ich heute bestimmt nicht an dem Punkt, an dem ich gerne sein würde.
Denn mit JavaScript...
Ja, und welche Frage ist es denn jetzt überhaupt?
...habe ich tatsächlich Spaß am Lernen gefunden.
Und die Frage, die du dir stellen solltest, ist...
...warum will ich programmieren?
Für mich war damals die Antwort...
Da gäbe ich ihm recht.
Tatsächlich, ja.
Das sage ich ja auch öfters.
Was will man machen?
Das kann natürlich schon...
Wenn ich spezielle...
Also, wenn ich gar keine Ahnung habe und einfach mir das ein bisschen angucken will,
dann sage ich defaultmäßig JavaScript.
Wenn jetzt einer sagt, ich möchte Windows-Desktop-Software erstellen,
warum auch immer man das als erstes machen will,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich eher nicht JavaScript.
...Antwort Webentwicklung.
Einfach, weil ich ein relativ visueller Mensch bin
und dann doch auch am Pixelschubsen ein bisschen Spaß finde.
Das war damals mein Warum.
Und deine Aufgabe ist es jetzt, dein Warum zu finden.
Willst du zum Beispiel...
Klingt ja richtig philosophisch.
...dann lernen doch C-Sharp oder C++.
Willst du irgendwie Maschinenprogrammieren, dann vielleicht eher C.
Willst du Daten analysieren, Python und R.
Und brauchst du einfach nur eine Altersvorsorge, dann lern doch einfach Java.
Mach dir jetzt also erstmal klar, wohin deine Reise...
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt Kobol.
...gehen soll.
Welche kleinen Dinge wolltest du schon immer mal programmieren und was macht dir...
Mal gucken, ob ich recht hatte.
Mal gucken, ob ich recht hatte, ob er da einen Shorts draus gemacht hat.
Shit.
Nein, hat er nicht.
Was sagt...
Aber ohne Scheiß.
Das ist doch wie gemacht, dieser eine Ausschnitt.
Daraus einen YouTube-Short.
Um Shorts zu bauen, oder?
Ich habe gewechselt...
Was jetzt?
JavaScript mit Elektron.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Kein Elektron.
Hör mal auf.
Es gibt schon zu viel Elektron, Krempel.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Lass mal.
Viele...
Was ist das denn?
Viele Hauseigentümer vergessen, diese wichtige Kleinigkeit regelmäßig zu tun.
Okay.
Das ist schon ein bisschen Clickbait, die Überschrift.
Aber...
Ich hoffe, ich erfahre jetzt, was ich machen muss.
Und es geht bloß zwei Minuten.
Was ist das für ein Teil?
Sieht aus wie...
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein...
Wie ein Filter oder sowas.
Viele Hauseigentümer vergessen, eine wichtige Kleinigkeit regelmäßig zu tun.
Okay.
Und zwar geht es um so einen oder ähnlich aussehenden Hauswasserfilter.
Wasserfil...
Lag ich schon mal gar nicht so verkehrt.
Diese Filter geraten gerne in Vergessenheit.
Einigen ist möglicherweise...
Ich glaube...
Ich habe sowas gar nicht.
Ist das...
Ist das Standard?
Hat jeder sowas?
Ich...
Ich habe sowas im Keller noch nie gesehen.
Ich glaube, ich habe sowas nicht.
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht bewusst, dass bei Ihnen so ein Wasserfilter verbaut ist.
Sie sind seit 2012 verpflichtend nach der Norm...
Sie sind seit 2012 verpflichtend.
Ich bin 2013 hier eingezogen.
Ich müsste eigentlich einen Dingsbums Wasserfilter haben.
...für Trinkwasserinstallationen.
Vielleicht habe ich auch einen und ich weiß es bloß nicht.
Neubau?
Nein, kein Neubau.
Die Wasserfilter müssen allerdings regelmäßig gereinigt werden.
In der Regel alle zwei bis drei Monate bei so einem Rückspülfilter.
Das kann man ganz einfach selbst machen und ist nicht viel Aufwand.
Ach, verpflichtend bei Neubau.
Werde aber doch gerne vergessen.
Nee, dann nicht.
Wie das geht, dazu gleich mehr.
Den Wasserfilter finden wir normalerweise im Haus...
Ich baue doch kein Haus.
Will ich arm werden in Deutschland oder wie?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich habe ein Haus geerbt und wir haben ein bisschen renoviert.
Aber das war es.
...Aus Anschlussraum.
Direkt hinter dem Wasserzähler sollte als nächstes der Wasserfilter montiert sein.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass keiner vorhanden ist.
Insbesondere bei älteren Gebäuden.
Wofür brauchen wir so einen Hauswasserfilter überhaupt?
Naja, lass mich raten.
Zum Wasserfilter.
Das Wasser sollte doch im einwandfreien Zustand vom örtlichen Wasserversorger kommen.
Das tut es im Prinzip auch.
Aber auf dem langen Weg durch die Rohrsysteme...
...können Fremdkörper und Schmutzpartikel, wie beispielsweise...
Boah, da schlafe ich ja gleich wieder ein.
Zum Glück geht das nur noch eine Minute.
...Rost oder Rohrabrieb in das Wasser gelangen.
Der Wasserfilter schützt unsere Hausinstallation vor diesen Fremdkörpern.
Am gängigsten sind Rückspülfilter.
Hört sich sinnvoll an.
Hier gibt es einen Drehregler, um die Reinigung auszulösen.
Wenn der Wasserfilter nicht direkt an das Abwasser angeschlossen ist,
müssen wir zunächst allerdings noch einen Eimer unterstellen, um das Wasser aufzufangen.
Klingt sinnlich.
Jetzt kann mit der Rückspülung begonnen werden.
Der Filter wird auf diese Weise gereinigt.
Kurz bevor der Eimer voll ist, sollte der Drehregler wieder rechtzeitig zurückgedreht werden.
Der Vorgang kann beliebig wiederholt werden.
Empfehlenswert ist es, diese Reinigung alle zwei bis drei...
Ich muss nachher echt mal in den Keller gehen und gucken, ob ich so ein Ding hab.
...ein Monate einmal durchzuführen.
Neben dem hier gezeigten Rückspülfilter gibt es auch noch Wechselfilter.
Hier muss die Filterpatrone getauscht werden.
Das ist aufwendiger.
Insbesondere in Mehrfamilienhäusern sind häufig auch Automatik-Rückspülfilter verbaut.
Sie sind direkt an das Abwasser angeschlossen und spülen sich regelmäßig selbst,
sodass keine Reinigung vergessen wird.
Ich hoffe, dieses kurze Video war nützlich.
Wenn ja, freue ich mich sehr über einen Daumen hoch und bedanke mich fürs Zuschauen.
Okay.
Ich gehe nachher mal in den Keller und gucke, ob ich auch einen Rückspülwasserfilter habe.
Zwölf Jahre nicht gereinigt, wenn ich einen habe.
Ja, vielleicht habe ich aber auch einen, der direkt ans Abwasser angeschlossen ist und sich selber reinigt.
Hat er ja auch gesagt, dass das funktioniert.
Also, könnte ja auch sein, ja.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe sowas noch nie gesehen bei mir im Keller.
Ich persönlich gehe davon aus, dass ich gar nicht so einen Filter habe.
Home Assistant Integration.
Oh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Gibt es sowas?
Wie hieß dieses Ding? Hauswasserfilter? Oder wie hat er das genannt?
Viele Hauseigentümer vergessen eine wichtige Kleinigkeit regelmäßig zu tun.
Hauswasserfilter.
Und zwar geht es um so einen oder ähnlich aussehenden Hauswasserfilter.
Mit WiFi.
Das ist was anderes.
Smart.
Gibt es nicht.
Okay.
Den gibt es nicht mit WiFi.
Oh, das aber.
Das sagt aber.
Ich habe gedacht, dass man vielleicht die letzte Spülung per WiFi übertragen könnte oder so.
Ich meine, hey.
Strom könnte sich das Ding sogar selbst generieren.
Irgendwie ab und zu mal aus dem Wasser, was durchfließt.
Macht Glück.
Moment.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, die haben sowas.
Nee, haben sie nicht.
Haben sie nicht.
Such doch was mit I2C.
Ja, du hast recht.
Ist nur die Frage, ob die überhaupt einen Anschluss haben hier.
Ich meine, die haben da drauf schon mal irgendeine, das ist eine Druckanzeige.
Die bringt ja nichts.
Ob es sowas mit I2C gibt?
Na gut.
Muss ich mal nachher gucken.
Die automatisch haben einen Kontakt.
Ja, ich meine, es wäre ja cool vielleicht auszulesen können, so wann der letzte Vibrationssensor.
Oh, Chat, jetzt seid ihr aber besonders high IQ.
Das könnte man natürlich machen, wenn der sich leert, dann vibriert er.
Und das könnte man mit einem Vibrationssensor tatsächlich gut feststellen.
Das ist sehr high IQ.
Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee.
Poggers.
Alles klar.
Was ist das hier?
Das wollte ich jetzt zwar nicht gucken, aber es geht nur fünf Minuten.
Upgrading Raspberry Pi 4 to 6.
Moment.
Hat er überhaupt genug Pins dafür?
Ich meine.
Das Maximum ist, glaube ich, 8G.
Warum nicht einfach ein Eintrag im Kalender?
Weirdchamp.
Einfach 16G runterladen.
So, lass mal gucken.
Wir skippen das vielleicht.
Wir skippen das vielleicht ein bisschen vor.
Je nachdem, wann der, wann der da anfängt zu löten.
Ja.
Hello, guys.
Today I got something.
I got something really special for you.
Thanks to one very kind man from Germany.
We're going to attempt the 16GB upgrade on the Raspberry Pi 4.
Gekommenet am Start.
Here we have a Raspberry Pi 4 Model B that I've prepared off camera.
So you don't need to watch me fight with the Captain Tape.
Also, this time I'm using metal shields that I diallied to better protect the plastic parts from the heat.
Okay, wo geht's los?
Now I'm securing it to my birth holder.
Und das ist ein reiner
Oh, das ist ein reiner
Der hat aber richtig krasses Equipment hier am Start.
Lötstellstation mit...
Leute!
Kommt euch diese Silikonmatte irgendwie bekannt vor?
Haben wir diese Silikonmatte schon mal irgendwo gesehen?
Er sieht fast aus wie meine Silikonmatte.
Nicht ganz.
Meine ist hier gerade und die im Seite sind schräg.
Aber, das ist mehr oder weniger fast die gleiche Silikonmatte, die ich, die ich auch habe.
Das ist bestimmt Wodka, ja?
Das ist nicht...
naja, das ist nicht, ja, ist auch klar, aber hier cool mit Absaugung und, ähm, Plusmittel hat er am Start,
das ist so eine komische Pumpe zum Entfernen, der hat schon eine nice Ausstattung, würde ich sagen, hier.
Moin Max, wie läuft's auf der neuen Arbeit?
Okay, hab ich jetzt schon eine Weile nichts dazu gesagt, ich hab Anfang des Streams was dazu gesagt,
ich find's sehr nice, leider vieles sehr umständlich, sodass man gar nicht wirklich produktiv gut arbeiten kann,
aber ich muss mich einfach mit dem Gedanken anfreunden, dass sie mich bezahlen, ob ich jetzt viel gemacht hab oder nicht,
weil es liegt ja nicht an mir, es liegt an sich Hürden, so nach dem Motto, ah, lass mal kurz den Helm-Chart installieren,
ah, fuck, von dieser Kiste gibt's kein Internet-Access und sowas.
Also, ja, wenn man für alles doppelt und dreifach lang braucht, dann bin ich auch halt doppelt und dreifach so langsam,
aber ich krieg nicht doppelt und dreifach so wenig Geld, sondern das Gleiche, also insofern ist eigentlich egal, ob ich langsam bin.
Also, da muss ich mich einfach dran gewöhnen, dass langsam sein dort anscheinend normal ist und nicht schlimm.
So, gucken wir uns mal an wieder, was der hier macht.
Aber Leute, wenn ich das Equipment sehe, was dafür notwendig ist, ich glaube nicht, dass es was ist,
wo mal eben bei Easy jemand daheim einen RAM-Upgrade von Raspberry Pi durchführt.
Hast du eigentlich auf der Arbeit jetzt irgendwie einen Linux-Zugriff?
Ja, ich hab sogar eine interne Linux-VM und eine Cloud-Linux.
Das Problem ist nur, man kommt davon nicht ins Internet.
Ich kann doch nicht mal Docker-Images gescheit bauen drauf, ohne die Docker-Files anzupassen,
weil die Docker-Files haben natürlich die normalen Docker-Images drinstehen, nicht irgendwelche komischen Proxys.
Warum nicht? Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, weil sie einem das Leben unnütz schwer machen wollen.
Wir reden hier von Testkisten.
Ich weiß nicht, warum Testkisten keinen Internetzugang haben.
Na gut, ist halt so.
Entweder mach ich abenteuerliche SSH-Tunnel,
oder ich bin einfach langsam as fuck.
In general, the problem with getting one of those is the minimum order quantity,
which in every supplier at this moment is way over 1000 chips.
And the thing is, one chip costs around $90.
Also, as you can probably tell, I finally got a new microphone,
and I really hope that this upgrade will make my videos more enjoyable for you.
Before we continue, I'm happy to announce the sponsor of this video.
PCB-WayT, a feature of a variety of advanced and high-quality services,
such as producing PCBs with up to 60 layers and SMD stencils,
advanced CNC machining, sheet metal...
Der hört sich ja auch sehr gehypt an, das Sponsoring zu machen, oder?
Geiles Sponsoring!
Der hört sich fast so motiviert an wie ich bei meinen Sponsorings.
...bending, injection molding, a variety of 3D-printing technologies,
including metal 3D-printing, while enabling you...
Aber meint der, ob der schon mal in einer Wüste gewesen ist?
...to customize every aspect of them.
All this at a very reasonable prices.
You can upload your designs, specify your requirements, and get an instant quote for your project.
Their PCBs start as low as $5 for 10 pieces.
You can find a link to their website in the video description.
Und es war auch sehr...
Man muss auch sagen, es war wirklich auch ein sehr zackiges Sponsoring.
As always, we first add some flux.
Okay, auf geht's.
Flussmittel, beste Leute.
Kann man nicht genug haben.
Wenn ihr lötet ohne Sponsoring, kann man nicht genug haben.
Denn ohne Flussmittel holt euch eine Tube, eine Spritze,
einen Stift, was auch immer, mit Flussmittel.
Flussmittel ist einfach PONG.
Also, ohne Scheiss.
Flussmittel lohnt sich richtig.
Kostet auch n...
Kostet nix, eigentlich.
Und ist viel angenehmer.
Du hast auch nicht das Problem,
dass du manchmal...
So einfach irgendwelche Brücken lötest zwischen zwei Pin...
Flussmittel ist doch im Lötsinn...
Да?
... Ja?
für den Lötzinn verwendest, ist das ja
so eine Mischung aus
Blei und
Zinn, glaube ich, und ein bisschen
Flussmittel innen drin. Ja, aber
das ist halt relativ schnell weg.
Das geht genau
für, es fließt halt
einmal an den Pin und dann ist es weg.
Wenn du ein bisschen was korrigieren musst
oder irgendwie
auch mal ein bisschen länger dran rumfuddelst,
dann ist halt
das Flussmittel aus dem Lötzinn schon weg.
Und wenn du sicher gehen willst,
dass du jetzt auch nicht zig Sachen
aus Versehen miteinander verbindest, gerade wenn es
besonders klein ist,
dann ist Flussmittel tatsächlich
das Mittel der Wahl. Und ich denke, das wird
man auch hier sehen.
Blei ist gewerblich verboten.
Ja, aber den normalen Lötdraht,
den man daheim kaufen kann, der
hat immer noch Blei. Ich glaube,
wie ist die Mischung?
20% Blei, 80%
Zinn oder so?
Man wird gleich sehen,
warum Flussmittel gut
ist, gehe ich mal von aus hier in dem Video.
Und dann using hot air
set to 420 degrees Celsius
and therefore 60%
we desolder the original memory
chip from the board. Here I saw
the tape was on the way of the chip,
so I decided to quickly change it.
Please be sure to check
if the solder is completely molten
before pulling on the chip
to avoid ripping off the solder.
Wisst ihr, was ich mich immer frage?
Wenn die da mit Heißluftzeug auf dem Board
rumpusten. Ja, der hat das
abgeklebt mit irgendeiner Reflektionsfolie.
Aber das Board wird doch so
heiß, dass ich da, wenn du Pech hast und was
bewegst, okay, du musst halt aufpassen, du darfst halt gar nichts
bewegen und das Board muss exakt gerade liegen.
Du lötest ja aus Versehen irgendwelche Dinge
ab.
Guck, ohne Flussmittel,
ohne, okay, beim
abmachen ist es nicht so wild, aber ohne
Flussmittel hätte es durchaus ein bisschen
rumschmieren können hier jetzt, dass das
übrig gebliebene Lötzinn. Und mit Flussmitteln
jetzt ist das alles schön an der Stelle, klumpt
sich wieder zusammen. Das ist viel
angenehmer.
Also ich hab's schon geschafft, mit
Heißluft aus Versehen Sachen abzulöten.
Ich hatte mal so
ein kleines, wie
hieß das Ding, Moment.
Automation
Pad.
So ein Teil. Ja, ein kleines, kleines
aber kleines.
Kleines Automation
Pad.
So ein Teil, genau.
Ja, ja.
So.
Und ich hatte,
ich hatte hier die Kontakte dran
und ich wollte diese Kontaktleiste ablöten.
Warum? Naja, weil ich's andersrum
draufstecken wollte, als es ursprünglich
gedacht war. Da wollte ich die Kontaktleiste
abmachen. Und es gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten,
wenn man sowas hier ablöten will. Entweder
du gehst an jeden einzelnen
Pin
und machst den heiß,
machst vielleicht mit ein bisschen
Kupfer das Lötzinn weg, hast so ein
komisches, so ein komisches
Sauge-Ding, um das Lötzinn wegzumachen
und das machst du dann bei allen, wieviel
sind das, 32 oder so, 32, 24,
was auch immer, Pins.
War ich zu faul für.
Was hab ich gemacht?
Ich hab von, ich hab von unten drauf gepustet
mit dem, mit dem Heißluft
ähm
und
zwei Probleme, die dabei
passiert sind. Das erste Problem war,
ich hab das
Plastik geschmolzen,
obwohl es unten war.
Ich hab das
Plastik vom, vom Dings geschmolzen,
und das
zweite Problem war,
also ich hatte das, ich hatte das, ich hatte das
ab, nee, nee, es ging dann ab, es ging ab,
ich hab's heiß gemacht, es ging ab.
Das Problem war nur, dass hier noch
Restzinn drinne war, ja, das heißt
ich konnte kein neues mehr reinstecken.
Also das ging ab,
aber hier war halt noch Restzinn drinne,
ich konnte kein neues reinstecken, ohne es alles
heiß zu machen, das heißt, ich hätte dann theoretisch
äh, alles heiß
machen müssen hier unten
und schnell ein neues reinstecken.
Was, was gar nicht so einfach ist.
Ich mein, du musst es heiß machen,
dann musst du die, dann musst du die, die, die,
ja genau, du hättest ein bisschen Kupfer drauf,
das, das war ich zu faul damals
für, ja, und dann musst du es wieder
reinstecken, und das alles
innerhalb von fünf Sekunden, und die Dinger sind heiß,
so, und dann hab ich halt
ein bisschen heißer gemacht, als es eigentlich sein sollte,
dass das Lötzinn länger flüssig ist,
um das reinzustecken, das
neue, und
dann hab ich das Relay abgelötet.
Ich hab das Ding halt schräg,
dick hingestellt, dass ich gescheit unten dran
komme, und auf einmal hat's gemacht
Blob, und das Relay lag bei mir auf dem Tisch.
War halt ein bisschen zu heiß.
Aber hey, aus solchen
Sachen lernt man, dass man's halt,
manchmal ist man schneller, wenn man's ordentlich
macht, auch wenn es
erstmal nicht so aussieht. Ja, und da
hätten mir tatsächlich Flussmittel auch ein bisschen geholfen,
weil mit Flussmittel hätte ich deutlich
einfacher, ähm, das, ähm,
das übrig gebliebene Lötzinn
abbekommen.
Da gibt's ja,
da gibt's ja so Kupfer,
weiß nicht, wie man das nennt, so Kupferdraht ist das,
so, so, so, so Kupfermesch,
das kann man draufhalten, und dann
macht man's warm, oder am besten hat man noch ein bisschen Flussmittel
drumherum, und dann saugt
sich quasi das übrig gebliebene Lötzinn
in das Kupfer rein, und dann
ist es weg.
Lötlitze heißt das,
genau, so sieht's aus.
Guck, jetzt sieht man
zum Beispiel auch, warum
Flussmittel
richtig gut ist. Guck mal,
der kann jetzt einfach, der kann jetzt
einfach sauber machen, und neues
Lötzinn da drüber schmieren,
und es stickt an der Stelle, wo
es sticken soll, und nicht quer
über das ganze Board. Guck mal,
das könntest du ohne Flussmittel
überhaupt nicht machen, kannst du komplett vergessen.
Das heißt nicht, dass ab und zu,
guck mal, mit was für einem riesen,
hier, ja,
Traube, Lötzinn, der
da drüber geht, das stickt wirklich nur an der Stelle, wo es
sein soll, das heißt nicht, dass du nicht
mal die ein oder anderen Sachen hast, die sich verbinden,
aber so easy, würdest du,
also das, könntest du ohne Flussmittel
gar nicht machen.
Das würde im Leben nicht funktionieren.
Jetzt macht das, jetzt macht das sauber, genau.
Solder Wick nennt sich das,
auf Englisch, also quasi
eine Löt, ein Löt,
Wick ist auf dem Kopf,
wie nennt man das auf Deutsch?
Perücke.
Also eine Löt, eine Lötperücke oder sowas
ist das doch, äh.
Make sure there is no solder left on the board.
Here I prepare my stencil
by cleaning it.
Okay, der hat halt einfach auch mal schon so ein vorgedrucktes Ding.
Naja gut, das hat auch nicht jeder.
Because the 16 gigabyte RAM chip
came with no solder balls.
And we need to re-bow it
in order to solder it.
Now I'm using
a little solder paste that I already dried.
Doch, ich dachte Wick,
ich dachte Wick ist so eine Perücke.
Oder schreibt man das mit G?
And we need to make sure to fill all the holes
in the stencil without any gaps left.
So all the balls can form even in size.
If you need...
Solder paste, ja, das ist quasi
so eine Art Creme mit kleinen Kügelchen
aus Lötzinn drinne.
Das ist halt, wenn man das an solchen Stellen
auftragen muss. Es muss halt kleben, aber
ohne zu löten.
Also es soll da dran haften bleiben,
aber es solle sich halt noch nicht verbinden.
Kann dir auch Fluss,
Flussmittelstift empfehlen.
Ja, genau, so ein Ding habe ich daheim.
Also hier neben mir in der Kiste liegen
so ein Flussmittelstift Flux.
So Super Fluxer heißt das,
glaube ich, was ich mir gekauft habe.
Hier Super Flux.
Oder?
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Mini Fluxer, Mini Fluxer hieß das Ding,
was ich gekauft habe.
Genau so ein Teil, so ein Stift
habe ich hier am Start.
Wenn ich mal was löten muss und.
So Flussmittel brauche.
Mini Flux, Mini Fluxer.
Wo sind wir stehengeblieben?
Hier.
Ich will jetzt mal gucken,
ob das klappt mit dem 16G Upgrade.
Need more details or step by step guide for the soldering process.
Super Flux.
Ne, wisst ihr, wie sich Super Flux anhört?
Super Flux hört sich an wie irgendein JavaScript Framework.
Oder nicht?
Keck, keck, JavaScript.
Wenn es hört sich Super Flux JS hört sich,
warte mal, Super Flux, das gibt es doch bestimmt schon.
Super Flux JS.
Wie?
Es gibt es noch nicht?
Wie jetzt?
Ich hätte werde, könnten das gibt es schon.
Be sure to check out my soldering tutorial.
This is how the chip should look like.
Okay, das ist, das ist anscheinend der 16 Gigabit RAM Chip.
Now I apply a little Flux to the board.
Flux, immer ordentlich Fluxen das Ganze.
And I try to align the chip as best as possible.
Warum hat er denn die Seriennummer geblurred?
Leute, habt ihr irgendeine sinnige Erklärung, warum er die, für was er die
Seriennummer hat?
Ist doch nicht so, dass man damit groß was anfangen könnte, oder?
Then using hot air set to 360 degrees Celsius.
Herkunft verstecken, ah, vielleicht hat das geknallt, nee, glaub ich nicht.
Vielleicht hat er die Seriennummer, vielleicht hat das ja aus illegalen
gecommoded Quellen irgendwie das Ding und will es nicht zurückverfolgen können.
And therefore 40 percent, we solder the chip in place.
When we are done soldering the new chip.
Guckt.
Und dafür ist halt auch Flux.
Flussmittel richtig nice, dass es eben unten jetzt nicht irgendwie zusammenklebt, sondern
dahin fließt, wo es sein soll.
Wobei ich sagen muss, es sieht nicht so wirklich gut connected aus, aber ich weiß nicht, wie
es richtig ausschaut.
We need to let the board cool down slow and even to avoid warping and possible damage
to the Pi.
After the board cools down, we power it and we hope for the best.
As you can see, the Pi starts.
Hope for the best.
Ist, glaube ich, echt gut beschrieben.
Ja, ich hätte das Ding schon direkt kaputt gemacht.
And boots to the system info screen detecting the 16 gigabytes of RAM.
Nice.
Now I will insert.
Das hätte ich, das hätte ich nicht gedacht auf der anderen Seite, aber schon, weil sonst hätte
uns das Video wahrscheinlich nicht gezeigt.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass man einfach den RAM Chip austauschen kann vom Raspberry Pi
und dann geht das einfach so.
With 64 bit Raspbian on it.
Sadly, after showing the colorful square.
The Pi gets stuck on a completely black screen and it's drawing around half an amp.
At this point I got two ideas.
The first one was to try to upgrade to another Pi and the second one was to try different
operating system, but none of those solved the issue.
The only operating system that worked was the RISC OS, but it has a limit to 4 gigabytes.
Ist das, ist das ein China-Chinesen OS?
The RAM.
Here I want...
Nee, limited anscheinend nicht.
... to say huge thank you to Jeff Gerling for helping with the software issue.
Make sure to check out his channel by the link in the video description.
Firstly, I wanted to release the video when everything is ready and working, but at this
point I thought it will take some time to figure out a solution to this issue so I decided
to release the video to show what I have done to this point and for sure there will be a
follow up video.
Also, Fazit ist, man kann es upgraden, der Pi erkennt auch 16 Gigabyte, nur dass der Pi danach nicht mehr funktioniert.
Okay, also aktuell eher keine so gute Idee.
Alles klar, ich hätte es eh nicht hinbekommen, weil ich, ich meine, ich hätte theoretisch alles dazu da,
aber ich würde es mich nicht, na, ich habe kein Mikroskop, ich habe kein Mikroskop dafür und ich habe auch keine, so, keine Vorlage.
Also, nee, ich könnte es, könnte es doch nicht machen.
Was, was können wir uns als nächstes sagen?
I tried finding hidden gems on AliExpress.
Please, nicht schon wieder AliExpress-Stell.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Chat, oh, nee, nee, jetzt habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Kann alles, macht alles und ist kaputt.
Auto-GPC ausprobiert.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Dein Zuhause.
Dein Zuhause wird noch smarter.
Noch?
Komm, wir gucken uns das CT-Video an.
Kann alles, macht alles und ist kaputt.
Auto-GPT ausprobiert.
Ganz ehrlich, als ich Auto-GPT zum ersten Mal benutzt habe, hat das bei mir eine körperliche Reaktion ausgelöst.
Also ein bisschen Schweißausbruch, ein bisschen Herzklopfen, so eine komische Mischung aus Faszination und der Gewissheit,
dass diese Technik ziemlich viel verändern wird und man noch nicht so genau weiß, ob das gut oder schlecht ist.
Und all das, obwohl die Software im Moment noch läuft, ist ein Sack Schrauben.
Auto-GPT ist sozusagen eine To-Do-Liste, die ich aufschreibe und die sich dann selbst abarbeitet.
Vor allem Auto-GPT.
Was ist das für ein Schrott?
Mein Browser kackt einmal im Stream neuerdings ab.
Das ist Windows-11-Shit.
Unter Windows 10 ist das nie passiert.
Ganz ehrlich.
Bisschen laut vielleicht, ja.
Okay, nochmal.
Als ich Auto-GPT zum ersten Mal benutzt habe, hat das bei mir eine körperliche Reaktion ausgelöst.
Also ein bisschen Schweißausbruch, ein bisschen Herzklopfen.
Warte, Leute, das liegt nicht an den Tabs.
Ich habe 64 GB RAM, Chrome hat damit keine Probleme.
So eine komische Mischung aus Faszination und der Gewissheit, dass diese Technik ziemlich viel verändern wird.
Und man noch nicht so genau weiß, ob das gut oder schlecht ist.
Und all das, obwohl die Software im Moment noch läuft, ist ein Sack Schrauben.
Auto-GPT ist sozusagen eine To-Do-Liste, die ich aufschreibe und die sich dann selbst abarbeitet.
Was?
Vor allem Auto-GPT überlegt sich selbst.
Also aus sich selbst heraus.
Wie ist die Aufgaben löst?
Guck mal hier, das tippe ich hier auf Englisch ein.
Denk dir 10 seltsame und niedliche Fantasie-Tiere aus.
Generiere Bilder von diesen Tieren und speichere die ab.
Das kann ich aber auch einfach in 1 zu 1 in Chat-GPT reinhauen.
Also warum brauche ich Auto-GPT jetzt an der Stelle?
Ja, und dann fängt das System an.
Und es macht mehr, als ich gefragt habe.
Es denkt sich Namen aus von den Tieren.
Es denkt sich Charaktereigenschaften aus.
Schreibt die in eine Liste.
Ja, und fängt dann an, Bilder zu generieren.
Ohne, dass ich die Bilder auszeichne.
Weil ich da irgendwie eingreife.
Das ist Drakonix.
Das Einhorn mit einem...
Massive Art.
Ja gut, warum nicht?
...einem großen Herz für alle Lebewesen.
Oder hier.
Finde heraus, wo Jan Kinojansen arbeitet.
Suche die Mail-Adresse von ihm raus.
Und schick ihm ein Foto von einem Schokokuchen und einem Raspberry Pie.
Und dann rödelt das System ein bisschen rum und...
Oh, Chat-High-IQ-Frage.
Ich kann es nicht beantworten.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Programmierung.
Du kannst doch eine Low-Level-Sprache lernen, um Gesetze der Physik in...
Aber warum muss es eine Low-Level-Sprache sein?
Du kannst solche Sachen auch wunderbar...
Also, wenn es jetzt nicht um Peak-Performance und Simulationen des Urknalls...
Keine Ahnung, was auch immer angeht.
Kannst du sowas doch auch in der High-Level-Sprache machen.
Weil es sich einfach angenehmer programmieren lässt.
Und gerade Python hat relativ viele Scientific Libraries.
Die selbst wiederum wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal in Python, sondern in C und C++ implementiert sind.
Also, wenn es um irgendwelche wissenschaftliche Dinger geht, würde ich aus Prinzip immer sagen...
Guck mal, ob es was in Python gibt.
Oder was im wissenschaftlichen Umfeld auch sehr beliebt ist.
Ist glaube ich Julia oder wie das Ding heißt.
Habe ich selbst noch nie benutzt.
Oder...
Oder ich glaube R.
Ich glaube R machen auch die ganzen Mathe-Leute.
Wobei, kein Plan von...
Guck mal, ob es nicht was Sinnvolles in Python gibt.
Lass dir vom Chain noch nichts mit Rust erzählen.
Ich glaube das ist in dem Fall gar nicht so sinnvoll.
Ja, also...
Ohne genaueres zu wissen...
So Scientific Zeug ist Python meistens das Ding schlechthin.
So, next.
Nach ein paar Sekunden herausgefunden...
Ja, Editor bei CT.
Und die Mailadresse auch.
Aber ganz wichtig nochmal zur Klarstellung.
Ich will hier keine aufgeblasenen Erwartungen aufbauen.
Das funktioniert alles noch nicht richtig gut.
Das ist ein Experiment.
Das ist buggy. Das ist unelegant zu bedienen.
Das funktioniert bislang auch nur auf Englisch.
Vor allem ist es auch gefährlich.
Also guckt auf alle Fälle...
Gefährlich?
Das ganze Video, bevor ihr selbst damit experimentiert.
Excellentes View-Time-Boosten.
Das müsste ich auch öfters einbauen bei mir in die Videos.
Ich müsste überhaupt mal wieder ein Video machen.
Mein letztes Video ist glaube ich drei Wochen her.
Aber ich gehe jede Wette ein,
dass das nur eine Frage von Monaten oder sogar nur Wochen ist,
bis das besser funktioniert.
Und das wird viel verändern. Ganz bestimmt.
In diesem Video erzähle ich euch meine Erfahrungen
mit AutoGPT und erkläre auch,
wie man das installiert.
Bleibt dran.
Das Intro, Alter.
Jedes Mal.
Internet-Server, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Fahrrad-Keno macht wieder Werbung in eigener Sache.
Alter.
Wie wachst du mit
Computerfunktionierung?
Werbung Ende.
Bislang war immer klar, wie Computer funktionieren.
Die arbeiten Anweisungen ab,
nicht mehr, aber auch nicht weniger.
Ja, unter der Haube macht das Chat-GPT
und alle anderen auch.
Die Anweisungen müssen klipp und klar sein,
dürfen keine Fragen offen lassen.
So funktionieren Computer ja, seit es Computer gibt.
Und jetzt, und ich glaube, das kann man so klar sagen,
gilt diese Regel nicht mehr.
Mit AutoGPT...
Ja doch, sonst würden sie ja nicht laufen
auf normaler Hardware.
... sagt man einfach, was man erreichen will,
was das Endresultat sein soll,
und wie der Computer dahin kommt,
kann er sich selbst überlegen.
Das klingt jetzt total profan, aber das ist krass.
Das ist wirklich eine elementare Veränderung.
Zum Beispiel bei meinem einfachen Beispiel
mit dem Herausfinden meiner Mailadresse.
Wollte man sowas bislang machen,
musste man das halt entweder irgendwie manuell recherchieren
oder so eine Suchfunktion selbst programmieren.
Und das ist gar nicht mal so trivial.
Also eine Websuche starten,
dann die Ergebnisse parsen
und hoffen, dass in den Daten der Suchmaschine
irgendwo die Mailadresse steht.
Dann geht es mit dem selbst geschriebenen Programm
nicht weiter, dann fährt das gegen eine Wand.
AutoGPT denkt sich dagegen
automatisch mehrere Wege aus,
um ans Ziel zu kommen.
Es googelt nicht nur, es guckt zum Beispiel bei meinem Fall
auch bei MugRack, so eine Journalisten-Datenbank,
und guckt...
... bei LinkedIn.
Bei einem meiner E-Mail-Herausfindversuche
hat AutoGPT den Arbeitgeber
der Zielperson gefunden,
aber nicht die Mailadresse.
Und dann hat er vorgeschlagen, eine freundliche Mail
an den Arbeitgeber zu schicken.
Das ist vielleicht keine allzu gute Idee.
Also, as a token of appreciation,
I have attached a picture of a chocolate cake
and raspberry pie.
Ah, ja.
Ja, da führt der Arbeitgeber bestimmt dazu,
bewegen interne Infos rauszurücken.
Und nach der Mailadresse der Person zu fragen.
Ich habe das dann abgebrochen,
aber ja, so würde das ein Mensch auch machen.
Ja, gut, vielleicht nicht mit einem Bild
von Raspberry Pie.
Jetzt mal wirklich Butter bei die Fische.
Was ist denn das jetzt genau, dieses AutoGPT?
Nicht mehr als ein experimentelles Python-Skript.
Das ist nicht mal ein ausführbares Programm,
sondern das ist im Moment wirklich nur
ein Skript.
Allerdings ein sehr beliebtes Skript.
Als ich für dieses Video recherchiert habe,
war AutoGPT das populärste Projekt
auf ganz GitHub.
Krass, oder?
Und wahrscheinlich gibt es das noch gar nicht so lange.
Dieser Plattform für Softwareentwicklungsprojekte.
Und nochmal kurz ein Disclaimer.
Weil gerade täglich sehr intensiv
an AutoGPT gearbeitet wird,
kann es sein, dass sich da schon wieder
Sachen geändert haben, wenn dieses Video herauskommt.
Was sich aber auf jeden Fall nicht verändert wird,
die Intelligenz von AutoGPT
kommt nicht aus den Python-Skripten,
sondern von außen.
Nämlich von OpenAIs, GPT-3.5
und GPT-4.
Also den großen Sprachmodellen,
die auch hinter ChatGPT stecken.
Statt aber halt manuell Fragen zu stellen,
promptet sich AutoGPT selbst.
Dafür muss man einmal
sein OpenAI-API-Key hier eingeben,
und mit einem normalen, kostenlosen ChatGPT-Account
kann man damit auch auf
platform.openai.com sich einloggen,
hier oben rechts auf den Account klicken
und sich dort dann einen API-Key rausgeben lassen.
Mit der kostenlosen Variante habt ihr
5 Dollar API-Guthaben.
Und so als Einordnung, während der Recherchen
für dieses Video, lief AutoGPT
mehrere Stunden lang durch
und hat bei mir dabei weniger als 3 Dollar verbraucht.
Beim ersten Start fragt
AutoGPT, wie die generierte
KI heißen soll.
Also zum Beispiel Tier-Ausdenker.
Okay, das heißt im Endeffekt
AutoGPT
generiert
selbst
Prompts über ChatGPT
um sich dann...
Ach du Scheiße.
Das geht so, ChatGPT lässt sich in Prompt generieren,
womit es dann ChatGPT wieder füttert oder sowas
in der Richtung.
Und das wichtigste
sind die Ziele. Die gibt man dann ein
und dann läuft das Skript los.
Und im Standardmodus muss man dann jeden Schritt
abnicken, was definitiv auch sinnvoll ist,
eben weil die Software noch total
buggy läuft. Und weil das System
nicht nur Prompts an die OpenAI
API weitergibt, sondern halt auch
Python-Skripte selbst generiert und
ausführt, da muss ich glaube ich...
Okay, das ist keine allzu gute Idee.
...nicht weiter erklären, dass das alles andere
als sicher ist. Man kann das System
auch autonom laufen lassen
und mir ist klar, dass das den wohl größten Reiz
darstellt. Aber hier sollte man wirklich
absolut wissen, was man da tut und
das niemals auf einem Produktivsystem
einsetzen, sondern wenn überhaupt in der
virtuellen Maschine...
Mit keinem lokalen Netzwerkzugang
auf jeden Fall. Ohne jegliche wichtigen
Daten. Weil das System aber selbst
denkt, also es völlig
unvorhersehbare Sachen machen kann,
ist auch der Betrieb in einer virtuellen Maschine
nicht sicher. Also immer
beaufsichtigen oder besser noch, guckt euch
das Video heran und wartet ab, bis
das Ganze stabiler und ausgereifter ist.
Jetzt aber genug Warnungen.
Was genau kann einem AutoGPT
denn jetzt schon für Arbeiten abnehmen?
NekoRock, nee, da sagt mir nix.
Ehrlich gesagt,
im Moment noch keine so richtig.
Bei meinen Experimenten hat das System
einige wirklich faszinierende Sachen
hinbekommen, habe ich euch ja am Anfang des Videos gezeigt,
aber es hat nie geschafft, die
gestellten Aufgaben wirklich komplett zu lösen.
Irgendwann ist das immer an irgendwas gescheitert
und hing in einem Loop fest, beziehungsweise
hat irgendwelche schon gelösten Aufgaben wieder
von vorn begonnen. AutoGPT kommuniziert
glücklicherweise immer sehr deutlich,
was es macht. Das ist ziemlich interessant.
Man gibt nur eine kurze Anweisung, also denkt ihr,
ich hole hier fünf Tiere aus und generiere Bilder von denen
und dann kann man mitverfolgen, was AutoGPT
denkt und was der Plan ist, nämlich
den Generate-Image-Befehl nutzen,
um Bilder von Fantasietieren
zu generieren und die Tiere als
Prompt für den Bildgenerierer
zu beschreiben. Und dann gibt es auch immer noch
eine Kritik, also wo das
System mitteilt, worauf es aufpassen
muss. Ich muss sicher gehen, dass ich die
Fantasietiere detailliert beschreibe,
sodass die generierten Bilder auch wirklich so
aussehen, wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Krass, oder? In AutoGPT sind so ein ganz
paar fertige Funktionen eingebaut,
also zum Beispiel ein Webcrawler
oder eine Bildgenerierung mit Dolly 2.
Dolly 2 ist ja auch von OpenAI und
weil man ja sowieso schon den API-Key für
GPT angegeben hat, kann AutoGPT
den halt auch direkt für Dolly
benutzen. Aber AutoGPT kann sich
auch selbst Funktionen programmieren.
Ich habe mal beobachtet, dass...
Sobald das anfängt, selbst was zu machen, wird es heikel.
Warum? Sobald das anfängt, selbst was zu machen,
macht es auch Blödsinn.
Das muss erstmal auf eine Fehlerquote kommen,
beziehungsweise auf eine
Kosten-zu-Nutzen-Ratio,
wo sich das sinnvoll ist, zu benutzen.
Ja, dann, also wenn wir
es schaffen, so ein Ding mal
irgendwie auf
menschliche
Fehler zu...
Nicht-Fehler zu bekommen und besser,
also jemand, der wirklich Ahnung hat von dem, was
er macht, wenn man irgendwie sagen
kann, okay, der macht 100 Sachen und
davon macht er einmal Kacke.
Wenn man solche Software auch in solche Regionen
bekommt, klar, dann macht das nicht nur
unseren Job,
ja, fragwürdig,
sondern so ziemlich alle Jobs fragwürdig.
Aber ich glaube, das wird
noch ein bisschen dauern.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Bum, badadings, badums, bum.
Wie auch immer. 32 Monate
massive subscription.
Das AutoGPT, als es
10 Bilder generieren sollte, ein Bild
mit Dolly 2 produziert hat und dann
auf einmal angefangen hat, zu recherchieren,
wie man sonst noch so Bilder generieren kann,
was komplett in die Hose gegangen ist.
Was ist das, was ich meinte mit den
unvorhersehbaren Ergebnissen?
Solche freien Recherchen von AutoGPT führen
meistens ins Nichts, weil man ja zum Beispiel
für viele Aktionen im Netz Accounts braucht
und die hat AutoGPT nicht
und kann die auch nicht anlegen.
Und es scheitert auch schon an irgendwelchen
Cookie-Bannern, wenn es Seiten unsurft.
So, und wie ist das mit den Falschinformationen?
Weil AutoGPT dazu tendiert,
Fakten live aus dem Netz
abzurufen und dann nur die
Suchergebnisse mit GPT analysiert,
neigt es deutlich weniger zu diesen
Halluzinationen, die man ja von
ChatGPT und Bing kennt, also so
komplett ausgedachten Quatsch.
Das funktioniert bei AutoGPT etwas zuverlässiger,
weil es die Fakten eben nicht aus seinem
Sprachmodell herauszieht, sondern eben
aus Google zum Beispiel.
Trotzdem sind bei meinen Recherchen manchmal heftige
Fehler aufgetreten, also
dass AutoGPT zum Beispiel gesagt hat,
ich würde in den Niederlanden arbeiten oder so.
Ja gut, das ist ja normal,
ChatGPT an sich denkt sich ja auch immer random
irgendwelche Bullshit aus.
Das ist definitiv noch ein Problem.
Was hatten wir letztens im Stream?
Wir haben noch ein paar Sachen ausprobiert,
da kam total, ja,
wie wir eine
Progress Bar
machen mit
dem
HTTP Client in C Sharp.
Da hat sich das Ding einfach Methoden
ausgedacht, die das gar nicht gab.
Also die der HTTP Client
überhaupt nicht hat. Hat das halt so hingeschrieben,
so als gäbe es das. Oh easy, so und so
muss das machen, das geht halt nicht.
Okay bitte!
Aber das ist asasyll.
Aber das ist das Problem.
Also bei der
CLIPSTATIONs-Programm
außerhalb der Jimmy-Style-Mode
benutzt AutoGPT für das
Selenium-Framework.
Es kann also passieren, dass es das Web
nicht nur im Text-Modus passt,
sondern manchmal geht auch ein Browserfenster
auf. Und offenbar, das konnte ich leider noch nicht testen,
kann AutoGPT damit auch grafische Elemente
und Bilder analysieren. Geht ja mit GPT-4,
das geht auch noch nicht es geht auch noch nicht chat gpt kann das im prinzip das haben sie nämlich
auch in ihrem trailer gezeigt aber dass selbst wenn du einen bezahlten chat gpt account hast
kannst du aktuell noch keine bilder hochladen und da irgendwelche dinge erkennen lassen na gut
man darauf allerdings über die api also die programmiert schnittstelle zugreifen muss man
sich bislang noch bei openair extra bewerben das habe ich zwar ach so ja okay ja gut die über die
developer api geht das ja aber normalsterbliche selbst wenn du 20 euro im monat oder was ist was
kostet es mittlerweile weiß gar nicht was kostet sie monat noch mal 20 dollar kannst du noch keine
bilder verarbeiten wurde aber noch nicht freigeschaltet deshalb konnte ich auto gpt nur
mit gpt 35 testen diese version würde auto gpt allerdings auch größtenteils verwenden wenn ich
zugeschaltet werde dann würde ich die gpt nur mit gpt 3.5 testen diese version würde auto gpt allerdings auch größtenteils verwenden wenn ich zugeschaltet werde
auf gpt 4 hätte denn gpt 4 ist in der nutzung ungefähr 30 mal so teuer wie gpt 3.5 turbo und
deshalb versucht auto gpt natürlich so viel wie möglich gpt 3.5 zu nutzen und switcht nur dann
wenn es vorteile bietet auf gpt 4 falls ihr jetzt denkt man kann gpt 4 doch mit der premium version
von chat gpt schon nutzen ja das stimmt aber openair erlaubt noch keinen api zugriff über
andere software und bilder halt auch nicht also zum beispiel auto gpt also erlaubt das schon aber
nur für leute die freigeschaltet sind
so und hier noch ein kurzes tutorial wie man auto gpt installiert alle links sind natürlich im
beschreibungstext hier unten die software läuft auf linux mac os und windows aber bislang nur auf
der kommandozeile es gibt zwar schon grafische benutzerabflächen davon lief bei uns aber keine
einzige mein kurzes tutorial setzt voraus dass ihr python installiert habt mindestens version
3.10 alternativ könnt ihr auto gpt auch über visual studio code dev container oder docker nutzen ich
zeige hier nur die python variante außerdem braucht ihr einen account bei openai den habt ihr wenn ihr
wie gesagt chat gpt nutzt so und die software selbst kriegt ihr von github einfach hier auf
auto gpt releases latest und dann hier unten source code runterladen es gibt keine ausführbare datei
weil wie gesagt alles nur python skripte die gepackten dateien entpackt ihr dann in einen
ordner und dann macht ihr eine kommandozeile auf unter windows brauche ich dafür übrigens admin
Das geht zum Beispiel so. Start-Taste drücken, CMD eingeben und dann Rechtsklick als Administrator ausführen.
Dann hangelt ihr euch über die Kommandozeile mit CD in den Ordner, in dem ihr AutoGPT entpackt habt und dort dann eingeben pip install –r requirements.
Ja, und dann unter Windows nie wieder loswerden.
TXT.
Man kann auch pip x verwenden für solche Dinge.
Dann wird alles installiert, was AutoGPT so braucht.
Kann man es einfach wieder entfernen.
Als das durchgelaufen ist, öffnet ihr die Datei .env.template in einem Text-Editor und tragt da dann euren OpenAI-API-Key an.
Wo ihr den findet, habe ich ja schon erklärt.
Dann speichert ihr die Datei als .env, also ohne das .template und je nach Betriebssystem kann es sein, dass euch Dateien mit Punkt am Anfang nicht angezeigt werden.
Unter Linux seht ihr die zum Beispiel nur mit dem Befehl ll und nicht mit ls.
Ja, und das ist...
ls-la zum Beispiel.
Oder so wie ich das immer mache.
Weil ich irgendwie so das gewohnt bin.
ls-lrth.
Das ist list all reverse time human readable.
Da kriegt man das Ganze aufsteigend.
Guck, also das unterste ist...
Oder absteigend, muss man sagen.
Das unterste ist das aktuellst bearbeitete Datei.
Und die Größen kriege ich in menschenlesbarem Größenformat angezeigt.
Deswegen mache ich immer ls-lacht.
Allerdings könnte man sowas natürlich auch ohne Probleme in ein Makro packen und irgendwie ll daraus machen.
Ja, also man könnte hier ohne Probleme irgendwie sowas sagen.
Wenn man das will.
Das war's schon.
Dann müsst ihr noch eintippen.
Python minus m auto-gpt, beziehungsweise wenn ihr keinen GPT-4 Zugang habt, Python minus...
Ja, ll ist genau, ist kein offizieller Befehl, das ist immer irgendein alias.
m auto-gpt minus minus GPT-3 only und dann läuft das.
Ihr werdet jetzt nach Namen...
Der KI und den Zielen gefragt und los.
Und wie gesagt, standardmäßig müsst ihr jeden Schritt mit y abnicken.
Ihr könnt aber auch y minus 20 eingeben, dann laufen die nächsten 20 Schritte autonom durch.
Gewarnt hatte ich euch ja.
Mein Fazit.
Auto-GPT ist für mich eines der faszinierendsten Stücke Software seit langem.
Also für mich zeigt das echt ganz deutlich, wo die KI-Reise hingeht.
Nicht nur, dass diese Systeme ermöglichen, ohne Programmierkenntnisse zu programmieren, sondern das sind natürlich auch persönliche Assistenten.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr könnt einfach, hey, ich brauche eine Schutzhülle für mein xy-Handy, bestellen wir mal bitte eine, die gute Bewertungen hat, ich will aber nicht mehr als 10 Euro ausgeben.
Oder machen wir mal bitte einen Termin beim Augenarzt in Hannover, am besten Mittwochnachmittag, zur Not geht auch Montagmorgen.
Man kann ja in vielen Arztpraxen Termine über Webinterfaces machen und das können solche Systeme natürlich relativ problemlos.
Also alles, was man im Internet machen kann.
Wenn das mal wirklich funktioniert, wäre natürlich extrem nice.
Werden diese Systeme sehr bald autonom bewertet.
Und es geht hier jetzt auch gar nicht darum, ob man das gut oder schlecht findet oder gefährlich.
Es ist einfach ganz klar, dass es diese Sachen geben wird.
Und wenn Menschen das nervige Arbeit erspart, werden sie das auch nutzen.
Wie fasziniert Leute von diesen Systemen sind, zeigt ja auch die Popularität auf GitHub.
Ich würde auf jeden Fall sogar noch weiter gehen und denken, dass solche Systeme viele normale User Interfaces, wo man irgendwas in irgendwelche Felder eintragen muss, um sich zum Beispiel eine Pizza zu bestellen, einfach verschwinden lassen wird.
Weil man einfach in normaler Sprache sagen kann.
Was man will.
Oder liege ich hier jetzt total falsch?
Was meint ihr?
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Ich freue mich darüber.
Und natürlich gerne abonnieren.
Tschüss.
See you.
Äh.
Wo sind die Tabs hin?
Wo sind die ganzen Tabs hin?
Ganz ehrlich.
Hier.
Warum hat es jetzt...
Warum hat es jetzt ein zweites Fenster aufgemacht?
Die Technik in diesem...
Das muss man jetzt nicht wirklich verstehen.
Oder?
Was haben wir denn hier als nächstes?
Dein Zuhause wird noch smarter.
Okay.
Ich habe den Millimeter Wave Präsenzmelder Akara FP2 ausprobiert.
Was kostet das Ding?
Was kannst...
Zeig mal kurz hier.
Akara FP2.
Komm, wir nehmen...
Komm, komm.
Wir nehmen einfach mal seinen Reflink.
Easy.
Currently unavailable.
Ja, geil.
Nice.
Die Technik in diesem Sensor wird unsere Häuser verändern.
Denn in Zukunft weiß dein Smartphone dann nicht nur,
ob irgendjemand an irgendeinem Bewegungsmelder vorbeigegangen ist
oder ob sich in einem Raum grundsätzlich irgendjemand aufhält,
wenn du einen Präsenzmelder verwendest,
sondern auch, wo...
Wir gucken einfach mal nicht bei...
Erstmal mal Geiz halt.
Akara FP2.
90 Euro.
AliExpress.
Ah, das ist der FP1.
FP2 gibt es hier gerade gar nicht.
Nun gut.
Gut.
...jemand in deinem Raum ist und bis zu einem gewissen Grad, was er oder sie gerade macht.
Und das eröffnet ganz...
Okay, das ist natürlich sehr praktisch, wenn du weißt, dass die Leute im Raum sind und wo sie im Raum sind.
Da könntest du zum Beispiel auch Fernseher einschalten, wenn sich einer aufs Sofa setzt und sowas ab 20 Uhr.
...wenn es dann wirklich gut funktioniert.
Das ist der...
Ah, will man?
Dann wird er wieder irgendein China-Chinesen-Ding haben?
Na gut, es funktioniert ja rein offline.
Akara FP2 mit Millimeter-Wave-Technik.
Ein Präsenzmelder, der genauer bestimmen kann, wo sich jemand auffällt.
Damit dein Wohnzimmer zum Beispiel reagieren kann, wenn du vom Esstisch zur Couch...
Ist das irgendwie so ein bisschen Radarmäßig oder wie funktioniert das?
Er braucht keine Bridge, er hat einen Helligkeitssensor verbaut, einen magnetischen und flexiblen Fuß zur Montage.
Und im Gegensatz zu seinem deutlich beschränkteren Vorgänger kommt er auch offiziell auf den deutschen Markt.
Ich habe ihn für euch ausprobiert, heute teile ich meinen ersten Eindruck mit euch.
Viel Spaß.
Schauen wir gleich mal rein.
Akara hat mir den FP2 übrigens auch vorm Markt statt zur Verfügung gestellt.
Haben aber ansonsten keinen Einfluss auf dieses Video genommen, haben es auch nicht vorher gesehen.
Ihr kennt das übliche Spiel.
So, hier haben wir das gute Stück.
Das mieseste Daumenkino der Welt.
Ein USB-C auf USB-A-Kabel.
Zwei Magnetplatten mit Klebepads und ein Dübel mit Schraube.
Der FP2 funktioniert per Wi-Fi.
Und generell die Millimeter-Wave-Technologie da drin braucht so viel Energie, dass wir hier von einem fest verdrahteten Sensor sprechen.
Was allerdings nicht...
Ist ja nicht schlimm, ist ja nicht schlimm.
Gerade im Wohnzimmer habe ich ja genug Steckdosen oder USB-Stecker, wo ich sowas mal reinmachen könnte.
Und es ist ja auch relativ klein.
Ja, also, ich glaube, da würde ich einen Platz für finden.
Was verdrahtet ist, ist das Kabel.
Also hier ist ein USB-C-Anschluss, es ist ein USB-C-Kabel dabei.
Ich würde sagen, wir richten den mal ein.
So, jetzt sind wir hier unten und ich habe den gerade professionell an die Wand montiert, um den hier im Wohnzimmer zu testen.
Und hier erkennt er mich.
Und ich kann mich rumbewegen.
Das ist cool.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Und der folgt mir.
Ich weiß nicht so richtig, warum ich so fasziniert bin von einem Punkt, der sich...
Das ist wirklich nice.
Damit kann man automatisierungstechnisch einiges anfangen.
Auf einem karierten Blatt Papier.
Man braucht es ja auch nicht überall.
Weil es ist ganz schön teuer, das Ding.
So ein normaler Bewegungssensor, so ein Presence Detection, den kostet 5 Euro.
Das kostet 80 Euro.
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Also ist schon ein bisschen teurer, aber damit kann man ganz individuell auf, sogar reagieren, so nach dem Motto da läuft nur einer durchs Wohnzimmer, macht das Fenster auf oder er setzt sich aufs Sofa und will jetzt Fernseh gucken und sowas.
Das ist schon nice.
Hier bewegt.
Ich habe aber gerade noch was anderes festgestellt.
Wir müssen gleich mal gucken, wo man das Ding irgendwie herkriegt.
Der Ballon hier, vom Geburtstag meines Sohnes, der ist ein Problem, denn der wird als Mensch erkannt.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Du kannst zwar grundsätzlich in der App Störquellen...
...so platzieren, dass die Software die rausrechnen kann, wenn zum Beispiel irgendwo eine große Pflanze steht oder so.
Aber der hier ist ja mobil.
Allerdings ist der Geburtstag jetzt auch schon eine Weile her, also löse ich das mit meiner üblichen Erziehungsmethode, dass Spielsachen, die in irgendeiner Form mir nicht genehm sind, einfach unauffällig verschwinden.
Irgendwann werden meine Kinder alt genug sein und sich die Videos angucken.
Dann wird ihnen einiges klar.
Jetzt muss ich aber irgendwie auch warten, bis mehr Einwohner nach Hause kommen, um zu sehen, wie gut der...
...der mit verschiedenen Personen klarkommt.
Bis dahin würde ich sagen, baue ich mal eben eine kleine Automation, die hier das Licht an- und ausschaltet, basierend auf An- und Abwesenheit.
Und dann können wir den auch gleich auf eine Schwäche von herkömmlichen Präsenzmeldern testen.
Die Geschwindigkeit.
Deswegen werden oft klassische Präsenzmelder, die mit Infrarot funktionieren, mit Bewegungsmeldern kombiniert.
Weil sie allein zu träge sind.
Und der Bewegungsmelder kann dann schnell Beleuchtung einschalten, sobald irgendwas passiert.
So wird das Licht zum Beispiel ausgeschaltet, wenn der Präsenzmelder sagt, na gut, jetzt ist halt keiner mehr da.
Das Problem hier ist natürlich so ein bisschen, dass die Tür zum Sensor öffnet.
Würde ich das dauerhaft installieren, würde ich das wahrscheinlich andersrum machen, damit der Sensor mich schon erkennen kann, wenn ich reinkomme.
So, ich betrete das Wohnzimmer.
Und in dem Moment, wo er mich sieht, das Licht an.
Von dem Sensor ausgehend kann der 8 Meter in die Tiefe und 6 Meter in die Breite...
Okay, das reicht für die meisten Räume, easy.
...geht aber im 120 Grad Winkel von da weg.
Er hat also hier irgendwo, bin ich noch im Bild, hier, hier so, hier und hier hinten einen toten Winkel.
Oder er hat einen 2 Meter Radius, also einen 4 Meter Durchmesserkreis, wenn du ihn 2,80 Meter hoch an die Decke dübelst.
Wenn deine Decke 2,80 Meter hoch ist.
Meine ist es nicht.
Wir können hier in der Zwischenzeit ja mal das Wohnzimmer so ein bisschen...
Meine Decke ist tatsächlich relativ hoch.
...einrichten, also mit dem einen Sofa hier grob einen Sofa-Bereich hin puzzeln.
So.
Und hier schieben wir den Fern...
Ah, das geht halt wieder nur mit der China-Chinesen-App.
Aber gut, mein, irgendwie musst du es mal einrichten.
Ich hab jetzt übrigens den Katzenbrunnen da, der mit dem Wifi-Wifi-Katzenbrunnen zum An- und Ausmachen.
Funktioniert ganz gut.
Funktioniert auch teilweise offline ohne China-Chinesen-Cloud.
Ich muss das mal eben kurz verifizieren.
Also er funktioniert komplett offline ohne China-Chinesen-Cloud.
Er muss nur irgendwie alle 3 Tage oder so mal seine China-Server pingen können.
Ja, okay.
Na gut, ein bisschen verschieben.
Hier ist der Esstisch.
Und dann können wir auf diesem kleinen Karopapier hier die Zellen nutzen, um bis zu 30 Zonen in unserem Zimmer festzulegen,
die dann einzeln irgendwelche Sachen triggern können.
Also wenn jemand auf dem Sofa sitzt.
Das ist schon cool, oder? Das hat was.
Wenn jemand am Tisch sitzt.
Wenn jemand, weiß ich nicht, hier vor dem Fernseher rumhampelt, am Kamin ist.
Bis zu 5 Menschen soll der gleichzeitig erkennen können.
Oder 4 und einen Helium-Ballon.
Und du kannst die Automation dann eben nach Anwesenheiten in der Zone erstellen.
Um das alles auszuprobieren, müssen wir auf die Familie warten.
Und während wir auf die Familie warten, habe ich noch einen kleinen Hinweis für dich.
Weil ihr euch gern mit neuen Informationen befasst, habe ich genau das Richtige.
Blinkist, der Sponsor des heutigen Videos, bringt Wissen komprimiert.
Und ich sehe, dass ich irgendwas bekämpfe.
Ich sitze einfach in Minuten und halte es unten zu.
Und übrigens, mein Kind, wenn das nicht automatisch klappt, ist es für die erneute Unterstützung.
So, hier sehen wir das Ganze mal mit vollem Zimmer.
Und ich muss sagen, das klappt überraschend gut.
Also manchmal...
Das Ding brauche ich.
Zumindest fürs Wohnzimmer.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr nicer Sensor für Automations.
Ich hoffe, das geht noch über SIGBIO.
Das geht noch über SIGBIO und braucht kein Thread und Meta.
Teilen sich herumlaufende Menschen kurzzeitig und dann verschwindet mal einer oder taucht irgendwo auf.
Aber ich würde sagen, unterm Strich funktioniert das.
Wenn du deine Aqara Bridge auf Version 3.5 aktualisierst, dann können darauf Automationen ablaufen.
Außerdem wird der Sensor und die Zonen auch an andere Systeme weitergegeben.
In HomeKit besteht der Sensor dann eben aus so vielen Teilsensoren für die einzelnen Bereiche,
wie du diese Erkennungszonen angelegt hast.
Leider erstmal unbenannt.
Du kannst zwar hier grundsätzlich die Bezeichnungen synchronisieren.
Also vielleicht kannst du das.
Ich konnte es nämlich nicht, weil die App mir gesagt hat, dass ich ein abnormales Netzwerk habe.
Also musste ich das auf die harte Tour beschriften.
Das ist China-Chinesen-Translation.
Die wollen einem bestimmt was anderes sagen.
Irgendwo hinsetzen, gucken, welcher Sensor angeht.
Ja.
Die HomeKit-Integration und die Automation, die du damit in HomeKit baust,
laufen ebenfalls alle lokal bei dir auf deinen Geräten in deinem Zuhause.
Wenn du Alexa oder Google Assistant benutzt, dann läuft das eben über die Cloud,
weil diese Systeme eben über die Cloud ihre Anbindung zur Verfügung stellen.
Es funktioniert aber im Prinzip genauso.
Du bekommst genauso einzelne Präsenzmelder für die einzelnen Zonen.
Nur es ist...
Für mich ist wichtig, dass ich es irgendwie Home Assistant gescheitmäßig integrieren kann.
Aber das meiste Akara-Zeug ist Zigbee.
Das sollte eigentlich funktionieren.
...etwas langsamer wegen des Umwegs über die Computer von jemand anderem.
Und Akara weist sogar ausdrücklich auf die Home Assistant-Integrationsmöglichkeiten hin.
Ich würde sagen, Akara scheint in diesem Fall einfach ziemlich viel richtig zu machen mit dem FP2.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit FFP2.
Aber das fast machen wir lieber nicht.
Und ich kann sagen, das ist alles schon ziemlich cool.
Also jetzt wirklich automationabhängig von der Nutzung hier im Wohnzimmer bauen zu können,
wer sitzt wo und was passiert gerade.
Und wenn sich eine Person dann vom Esstisch mit aufs Sofa setzt,
dann kann das Licht am Esstisch automatisch in den Ambiente-Modus wechseln.
Und auch dabei ist natürlich der eingebaute Helligkeitssensor hilfreich,
damit die Beleuchtung nicht bei gleißender Mittagssonne angeschaltet wird.
Und wenn ihr HomeKit-Automationen mit Bedingungen bauen wollt,
und ihr werdet viele HomeKit-Automationen mit Bedingungen bauen...
Nee.
Keine HomeKit-Automationen.
Aber Automationen, ja.
Wenn ihr das Teil mit HomeKit benutzt, dann verlinke ich euch unten die Eve-App und HomePlus.
Die machen das möglich und angenehmer.
Du kannst aber zum Beispiel auch im Schlafzimmer Aufwach- oder Schlafungsautomationen bauen
und dabei abfangen, ob vielleicht noch jemand anderes im Zimmer ist
oder vielleicht sogar noch im Bett liegt.
Und dann kein Licht anschalten oder so.
Oder nur irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, irgendwas unter dem Bett, damit du den Weg zum Klo findest.
Du kannst das in deine Alarmanlage mit einbauen,
ohne dir Kameras in Innenräume hängen zu müssen.
Also, wenn niemand zu Hause ist, aber eine Präsenz erkannt wird
und kein Heliumballon anwesend ist, soll zum Beispiel der Alarm losgehen.
Das einzige, was der Sensor sieht, ist ja irgendwie so eine Punktewolke aus Dingen,
die seine Mikro- oder seine Millimeterwellen stören.
Und dann hat Acara obendrauf noch einige Funktionen angekündigt, die per Update kommen sollen.
Und wie immer, kaufe den FP2 nicht,
nicht wegen dieser angekündigten Funktionen,
zumindest nicht, solange sie nicht inzwischen da sind.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wann du das Video schaust.
Aber in Zukunft sollen per Update kommen.
Ein Meta-Update, das würde dann auch für die anderen Systeme...
Ich hoffe, dass es aktuell über Zigbee geht.
Ich meine, Meta ist ja an sich eine Ebene oben drüber.
...lokale Verarbeitung und damit mehr Geschwindigkeit bringen
und generell die Möglichkeit, das in jedes System zu integrieren.
Eine Haltungserkennung.
Also jetzt nicht politische Gesinnung, sondern eine Unterscheidung,
ob du liegst, sitzt oder stehst.
Hat er WLAN gesagt? WLAN ist auch okay.
Eine Schlafüberwachung. Es soll Menschen zählen können.
Also der Sensor oder ein zusätzlicher Sensor würde dir dann einfach eine Zahl zurückgeben,
wie viele Menschen irgendwo erkannt wurden.
Und, und das ist wahrscheinlich das Wichtigste,
mehrere FP2 auf einer Karte platzieren zu können.
Das wäre natürlich einige...
Ah, das wäre cool. Das wäre cool.
Also Emco, ich denke den meisten schon.
Bisschen spooky, warum?
Es ist ja nur rein lokal bei dir.
Also da sehe ich jetzt, sehe ich jetzt aktuell kein großartiges Problem drinne.
...gegenmaßen notwendig, wenn du zum Beispiel ein größeres Zimmer
oder eine ganze Wohnung damit ausstatten wollen würdest.
Akara sagt, dass sie auch weniger Probleme mit höheren Umgebungstemperaturen haben
und dann nicht so unpräzise werden, wie das bei den klassischen PIR-Sensoren der Fall ist.
Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich habe das extra für euch getestet.
Auf keinen Fall ist einfach die Batterie in einem unserer Heizungsthermostate leer gelaufen
und hier waren es gestern karibische 27 Grad im Wohnzimmer.
Aber ich kann sagen, auch dabei hat die Erkennung weiter problemlos funktioniert.
Das klingt alles eigentlich ziemlich gut, oder?
Das Ding ist halt teuer. Und schlecht.
Und schlecht lieferbar anscheinend.
Das klingt alles eigentlich wirklich ganz gut.
Grund genug, dem Ganzen jetzt nochmal schön in die Parade zu fahren.
Denn der erste und offensichtlichste Punkt, und ihr seht ihn hier an meiner Wand,
diese Sensoren zu platzieren ist nicht ganz so einfach, weil sie eine Stromversorgung brauchen.
Du kannst sie natürlich auf einem Highboard aufstellen
und das ist wahrscheinlich in vielen Räumen einfach die offensichtlichste Option.
Das sollte aber mit einer Fixierung einhergehen, damit dein Grundriss passt.
Denn wenn du den nur ein bisschen drehst und dann irgendwie 3, 4, 5 Meter Abstand,
dann wird das schon einfach ganz woanders sein.
Wenn du ihn so wie ich an der Wand oder vielleicht sogar an der Decke platzieren willst,
brauchst du da eben Strom.
Und zumindest das wird sich auch nicht ändern.
Etwas schwammiger sind da meine anderen Kritikpunkte.
Ich weiß, wo ich es hinhänge, Leute. Ich weiß genau, wo ich es hinhänge.
Ich habe die Idee, ich hänge das einfach dort, wo mein WLAN-Accesspoint an der Decke hängt,
weil der hat noch einen USB-Anschluss und da könnte ich einfach 5 Volt DC abgreifen.
Da muss ich kein extra Kabel legen, da liegt ja schon ein PoE-Kabel hoch zum Accesspoint.
Einige Probleme hatte der Sensor aber mit weiteren Firmware-Versionen immer besser wurde.
Anfangs hatte ich noch hin und wieder sehr wirre und irre Bewegungen
und das konnte ich zum Beispiel seit dem letzten Update gar nicht mehr beobachten.
Unsere Kinder werden einigermaßen zuversichtlich erkannt, wenn sie im Wohnzimmer herumrennen.
Aber wenn meine Tochter zum Beispiel in einem Wohnzimmer sitzt,
zum Beispiel am Tisch sitzt und bastelt und der Tisch vor dem Sensor dann auch noch die Beine verdeckt,
dann wird sie oft nicht erkannt.
Reicht 5 Volt 1 Ampere?
Wahrscheinlich wird das reichen.
Das kann natürlich je nachdem, was ihr für Haustiere habt, ein Faktor sein.
Über den Helium-Ballon haben wir gesprochen.
Stationäre Störenfriede kannst du, wie gesagt, in der Karte ausblenden.
Habe ich nicht. Wir haben keine großen Pflanzen hier.
Wir haben eben ein sehr spartanisches Leben.
Und wir hatten ein Kind, das gern Blumenerde gegessen hat.
Die verschiedenen HomeKit-Sensoren sind auf jeden Fall auch ein bisschen träger als die Anzeige in der App.
Allerdings ist es schwer zu sagen, ob das jetzt an Acara...
Ja gut, das muss ja auch erstmal übersetzt werden zu HomeKit und HomeKit muss das mitkriegen und alles.
...oder an HomeKit liegt.
Denn auch auf Apples Seite hat man sich ja jetzt in den letzten Monaten nicht unbedingt mit Ruhm bekleckert,
was Zuverlässigkeit und Schnelligkeit und so angeht.
Und manchmal hatte ich auch das Problem, dass der Sensor, aber meistens die App, die Anzeige nicht mehr aktualisiert hat.
Also der Sensor nicht die Anzeige, aber das, worauf er reagieren soll.
Ein Neustart der App hat dann meistens geholfen und dann wurde ich auch wieder im Raum angezeigt.
Ja du, das Problem habe ich dann mit Home Assistant Integration hoffentlich nicht.
Und auch das ist fast nicht mehr aufgetreten seit dem letzten Update.
Jetzt, nachdem ich mit dem FP2 eine Weile einen Millimeter-Wave-Präsenzmelder hier im Wohnzimmer hatte,
habe ich das Gefühl, die Zukunft gesehen zu haben.
Wenn meine Hausautomatisierung versteht, wo und zu einem gewissen Grad und mit zukünftigen Updates dann noch mehr,
was gerade im Haus passiert, dann eröffnet das unglaublich viele neue Komfortfunktionen.
Ich kann mich gar nicht ausmalen, auf was für Ideen ihr noch alles kommen werdet.
Und ich habe zum Beispiel ja die ganze Hinfallerkennung nicht mal ausprobiert,
weil ich nicht Lust hatte, mit Tesa Crepe hier auch nochmal den ganzen Käse an die Decke zu montieren.
Aber allein diese eine Geschichte kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das kann im Pflegekontext natürlich auch fantastisch sein.
Aber habe ich die Gegenwart gesehen, also läuft das schon alles absolut rund,
noch nicht so richtig.
Manchmal scheint der sich ein bisschen aufzuhängen, manchmal dauert das ein bisschen.
Egal, so ein Teil brauche ich.
Wo kriege ich das her?
Wo kriege ich da aktuell einen her?
Shopping.
Alza.de
Was ist das denn?
China-Chinesen-Dropshipping?
Auf Bestellung Daten werden angegeben.
Hä?
Was?
Auf Bestellung Daten werden angegeben?
Was wollt ihr mir sagen?
Laut Video war der noch nicht released.
Ah ja, das kann natürlich sein.
Dass es noch ein bisschen dauert, bis das Ganze rausgekommen ist.
Wobei in dem Video...
Jaja, ist ja gut.
In dem Video...
Ich finde das jetzt nicht...
Ich habe den Link drinnen gehabt und da war es gerade nicht lieferbar.
Das ist ein Acara FP2, ein Presence Detection Sensor,
der erkennt, wo du im Raum bist und relativ in Echtzeit die Position updaten kann.
Das klingt sehr sinnig, ja.
Aber gut, wenn die jetzt alle reviewen vor zwei Tagen,
dann gibt es das Ding normal noch nicht zu kaufen.
Es wird Zeit, würde ich sagen...
Ist das das?
Es wird Zeit, Smart Home Influencer zu werden, oder?
Chat.
Würde ich sagen.
Dann kriege ich sowas auch geschickt.
Was möchte ich mir AliExpress sagen?
2023 hochpräziser Bewegungssensor.
Sensor für den menschlichen Körper mit ZigBee.
Wahrnehmung der wasserdichten Arbeit des menschlichen IPX5 mit HomeKit.
Das ist so eine typische China-Chinesen-Übersetzung, Alter.
Wahrnehmung der Wasserdichten.
Wahrnehmung der wasserdichten Arbeit des Menschen.
Alles klar.
Super, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, ja.
Welcher ist das denn jetzt überhaupt?
Welcher Sensor?
Steht da nichts drauf?
Das ist wahrscheinlich der FP1 noch, oder?
Ach, Motion Sensor.
Oder was anderes.
Anscheinend gibt es eine HA-Integration nicht möglich ohne die Aqara Bridge.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Mal ein bisschen abwarten.
Aber ich fand den Sensor schon sehr nice.
Also das brauche ich auf jeden Fall.
Wichtig, wichtig, wichtig.
Also damit kann man sehr viel, wirklich mega viel nices Zeug machen.
Das gefällt mir.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Off Topic, warum benutzt du eigentlich X anstatt von Wayland?
Weil Wayland in der VM nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Und mit gescheit nicht funktioniert meine ich, es funktioniert gar nicht richtig.
Es updatet den Bildinhalt nicht.
Also useless.
Ja, ist es.
Wobei Xiaomi hat ja sehr viele Unter-Brands.
Und Aqara ist eins davon.
Es geht alles über diese Mi Home App.
Teardown FP2 Sensor.
Ja gut, wirklich viel erkennen tut man da ja nicht.
Ist ein ESP200, sagt man ja.
Hier hat einer einen Teardown gepostet von diesem Sensor.
Guckt mal.
Und wisst ihr was man daran cooles sieht?
Taucher Container als VM.
Joa.
Guckt mal.
Ich mach das mal groß.
Was fällt euch hier auf?
Was ist das erste was hier auffällt, Leute?
Das Modul kommt uns irgendwie bekannt vor, oder?
Das ist ein ESP32.
Da haben wir auch schon ein paar am Start gehabt.
Allerdings die restliche Hardware haben wir natürlich nicht.
Das heißt potenziell.
Potenziell könnte man dafür sogar Custom Firmware machen.
Wobei es halt schwierig wird.
Da ist halt auch viel Software drauf, was diese Erkennung dieser Wellen macht.
Also insofern würde ich mal sagen, okay.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eher schwierig mit Custom Firmware.
Aber man könnte das Ding zum Beispiel relativ gut erweitern mit irgendwelchen Custom Sensoren.
Gut, ist halt die Frage, wie man die dann ausgelesen bekommt.
Also, joa.
Aber schon mal nice, dass da ein ESP32 drinsteckt.
ESP32.
ESP32 Based.
Und da kommt ja auch an die Kontakte außen dran.
ESP32 Based ist immer äußerst nützlich.
Falls man wirklich mal was machen muss in Zukunft.
Sehr nice.
Pogu.
Ja.
Ich hab mal kurz was abchecken.
Nope.
Oder auch nicht.
Ähm.
Alles klar.
Das könnte tatsächlich sein, dass da noch ein anderer Chip drin ist.
Ja.
Das könnte tatsächlich sein, dass ESP32 hauptsächlich die WLAN Sachen halt, WLAN Connection macht und hier unten drunter noch mehr ist.
Aber ist schon mal cool zu sehen, dass ein ESP32 drin ist.
ESP32 ist immer praktisch.
Ohne Mist.
Mir ist jedes Smart Home Gerät mit dem ESP32 recht, weil da kann man im Zweifelsfall von Hand dran und was bauen.
Wollen wir mal, ob wir da noch ein bisschen mehr Bilder von haben.
Das ist der Sensor.
Was bin ich sehend?
Okay, das ist der Sensor.
Tja.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wenn es das Ding, Groove Electric, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wenn es das Ding lieferbar gibt.
Da werde ich mir auf jeden Fall instant einen kaufen und ausprobieren.
Weil die Anwendungsgebiete klagen wirklich sehr nice.
Okay, noch ein drittes Bild.
Okay.
Drittes Bild.
Ah, hier.
Das ist der Sensor.
Ja, das wird hier, das wird hier alles drauf passieren und dann.
Das ist der Typ, der diese Datenbank hat mit dem Sensor.
Das ist der Typ, der diese Datenbank hat mit Tasmotor-Geräten.
Vielleicht gibt es irgendwann auch wirklich Tasmotor-Support.
Verwende ich nicht, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Klingt aber auf jeden Fall nach einem äußerst Pogu, nach einem sehr nicen Sensor.
Warte doch mal.
Quatsch, ich warte, bis es das Ding zu kaufen gibt, anstatt es dann mit denen ewig rumzuschreiben.
Kein Bock.
Kein Bock, wirklich nicht.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
I tried finding hidden gems on AliExpress.
Again.
Part Four.
Okay.
Dann lasst uns doch mal hidden gems von AliExpress zeigen.
Warum habe ich eigentlich die Fenster hier?
Brauche ich doch gar nicht mehr.
Daniel, danke für den Sub.
So.
Lass mal gucken.
If you buy yourself an AliExpress product with a five star rating, only to find out.
Na gut, AliExpress five star ist ja fast normal.
Da gibt es kaum was unter 4,8 oder sonst was Stern.
Aber gut.
Ich meine, bei AliExpress Bewertung würde ich da gar nichts drauf geben.
That it performs terribly.
But that is why this video series exists, in which I test all kinds of AliExpress products
to tell you whether you should check them out or simply ignore them.
And in case you are completely confused right now, AliExpress is an online shop based in
China, where you can not only get the newest, weirdest and sometimes super-
Die Dinger hier sind enorm praktisch.
Wisst ihr, was das ist?
Das sind, wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Ich habe, ich habe vergessen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Ding auf Deutsch heißt.
Also zumindest funktioniert das folgendermaßen.
Du hast hier so einen, so einen Plastik, Plastikschlauch mit Lötzinn in der Mitte und Kleber links und rechts.
So.
Und dann steckst du.
Warte mal.
Ich zeige euch das mal bei Amazon.
Lid, Schränk, Tube, Löt, Lötdichtung, Drahtverbinder, sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Nennt sich Lötverbinder.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Ja, okay.
Ja, hier sieht man es, hier sieht man es ganz gut.
Und zwar.
Ich nehme lieber, wo die Dinger umgedreht liegen.
Hier sieht man es gut.
Sehr, sehr, sehr gut.
Also hier sieht man es, hier sieht man es.
Also man nimmt sich so ein Ding, steckt hier quasi ein Kabel rein, steckt hier ein Kabel rein.
Kann man das nicht einfach irgendwie so mal aufmachen?
Also steckt hier unten ein Kabel rein bis in die Mitte.
Also hier kommt man durch.
Ja, man kann die auch überlagern.
Man kann hier so ein Kabel reinstecken, hier ein Kabel reinstecken.
Und dann macht man folgendes.
Man nimmt ein Feuerzeug oder ein Heißluftgebläse, Föhn, wie auch immer man das nennt.
Kein Föhn.
Also so ein Heißluft-Pistolen-Ding, so ein Heißluft-Föhn-Ding, wie auch immer man das korrekt nennt.
Also Heißluft oder man nimmt ein Feuerzeug.
Oder was auch immer.
Ich mache es meistens mit einem Feuerzeug, wenn es schnell gehen muss.
So, dann erhitzt man hier in der Mitte das Lötzinn.
Dann schmilzt das Lötzinn quasi erstmal die Kabel in der Mitte zusammen.
Und das hier ist noch ein Schrumpfschlauch.
Also man macht im Prinzip, macht man das Feuerzeug erstmal in der Mitte, bis es schmilzt.
Und dann macht man hier noch ein paar weitere.
Und dann macht man hier noch ein paar mal hin und her.
Und dann passiert folgendes.
Es lötet die Kabel zusammen.
Es schrumpft den Schrumpfschlauch.
Und es schmilzt den Kleber hier drin.
Hier ist Kleber drin.
Das heißt, man hat dann wirklich eine bombenfeste, wasserdichte Verbindung zwischen zwei Kabeln.
Die kriegst du auch nicht mehr auseinander so ohne weiteres dann.
Das ist halt fest zusammen.
Und dadurch, dass du einen Schrumpfschlauch drum hast, kannst du es anfassen danach und es passiert nichts.
Und durch den Kleber.
Und das Zusammenziehen ist es auch wasserdicht.
Also das ist die einfachste und schnellste Variante, um zwei Sachen zusammen zu können.
Was spricht gegen einen normalen Schrumpfschlauch?
Nichts.
Außer, dass es länger dauert.
Beim normalen Schrumpfschlauch musst du erstmal den Schrumpfschlauch auf eine Seite drüber machen.
Dann musst du es zusammenlöten.
Dann machst du den Schrumpfschlauch über die Stelle.
Dann schrumpfst du den Schrumpfschlauch.
Wobei der normale Schrumpfschlauch keinen Kleber hat.
Kommt auch dabei.
Aber ansonsten spricht da nichts dagegen.
Kannst du machen.
Und ist vielleicht.
Gerade wenn du was bisschen kleineres brauchst.
Was ein bisschen kompakter ist.
Ist ein Schrumpfschlauch natürlich sinniger.
Weil die hier sind ja relativ lang.
Also wenn du wirklich sowas brauchst.
So ein halbes Zentimeter zum verbinden.
Dann nicht.
Aber ansonsten.
Wenn du einfach nur schnell zwei Sachen miteinander verbinden musstest.
Das finde ich das beste und einfachste, was du machen kannst.
Lüsterklemme in 2023 quasi.
Ne.
Die Lüsterklemme 2023.
Da würde ich mir irgendein Vagoklemmenset kaufen.
Die sind auch nice.
Sowas hier.
Ja.
Würde ich mir hier irgendwie so ein Set kaufen.
Und wenn man wirklich Kabel.
Also planke.
Kupferkabel.
Oder planke Kabel hat.
Die man zusammen klipsen muss.
Dann sind die Dinger sehr praktisch.
Und mit einem Set.
Hat man halt auch die Möglichkeit.
Also.
Wieder aus.
Also mit diesem Set.
Du kriegst die Kabel auch wieder auseinander.
Nicht wie bei diesem Lötverbinder.
Die sind halt zusammen gelötet.
Die kriegst du so ohne weiteres nicht mehr auseinander.
Außer du machst halt alles wieder heiß.
Und zerstörst die Verbindung.
Und hier kannst du halt rein klipsen.
Sind übrigens mehrfach verwendbar.
Nicht nur einmal.
Und das hält auch bombenfest.
Sind für alle möglichen Kabeltypen.
Also verwendbar.
Für Litzen.
Also für Litzen.
Also für quasi Drähte.
Und für.
Ja.
Massive Kabel.
Und du kannst natürlich.
Im Vergleich zu so einem Lötverbinder.
Auch aus.
Ja.
Einem Kabel mehrere machen.
Also du hast halt hier welche.
Bis zu.
Ähm.
Ja.
Bis zu fünf.
Fünf Anschlüsse.
Dann machst du auf die.
Eine Seite des Kabel.
Und kannst dann quasi viermal.
Das damit verbinden.
Also sowas.
Also diese zwei.
Diese zwei Sachen in Kombination.
Ähm.
Vago Clam Set.
Und so ein paar Lötverbinder.
Da hast du quasi neun neunzig Prozent.
Alle deiner.
Ähm.
Verbindungs.
Verbindungsneeds.
Abgedeckt.
Mit.
Du du du.
Du du.
YouTube ist unbedingt der Meinung.
Wir sollen uns das angucken.
Wissen schon.
Ja.
Aus.
Über.
Also's muss mal runter.
Ja.
Praktischer.
Oder müssen wir ein raus nehmen.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Also dass ist drei.
Wir müssen.
Nein.
Was haben wir hier.
Ne.
Wir müssen.
No.
Ja.
Wir müssen.
aan.
Ö.
E felicita.
Ja.
Genau.
So.
wird bescheuert das ist ein geschäftsmodell für die gruppen oder nicht für die leute die in die
gruppe gehen ans trinken erinnern sehr gute idee ein richtiger reminder wäre ich jetzt hätte ich
nicht daran gedacht ok lasst uns mal das video mit den mit den hidden gems auf aliexpress noch
mal fertig gucken jetzt sagt sagt bei useful products but also lots of garbage ja aliexpress
ist voller garbage aber es ist halt also es war in der vergangenheit wirst du das neue zelda zocken
auf jeden fall ja ich glaube ich habe noch kein ausgelassen das wollte ich jetzt sagen ja also
bei aliexpress ist halt richtig nice elektronik teile zu kaufen weil die lange zeit ich weiß ich
habe lange schon ich bestimmt jetzt schon zwei jahre nichts mehr dort bestellt es hat sich halt
wirklich gelohnt das war halt sehr günstig also konnte es auch größere mengen sehr günstig kaufen
und es hat sich gelohnt und dafür war aliexpress so gut wie es war und dafür war aliexpress so gut
aber du musst es halt gucken das was es gibt auch wirklich viel shit auf aliexpress man muss aber
sagen ich hatte mit dem aliexpress support bisher nur nur gute erfahrungen also ich hatte mal ich
weiß gar nicht was es war ich kann mich wirklich nicht mehr erinnern was es war ich kann mich nur
noch an den an den aliexpress support fall erinnern ja die haben gesagt sie haben es los
geschickt und haben es nicht losgeschickt haben immer gesagt ja es dauert noch ja es dauert noch
ja es dauert noch und irgendwann habe ich dann bei aliexpress mal so einen wie war
es bei paypal ihr kennt es ja vielleicht bei paypal kann man doch auch so kunden weiß ich
wie es problemfall problemlösungsfall aufmachen bei paypal ja sowas habe ich auch bei aliexpress
aufgemacht und die haben gesagt okay ich soll mal einen tag warten sie kontaktieren den hersteller
dann hat er konnte hersteller mich kontaktiert hat gesagt lieber kunde wir haben ihr produkt
jetzt erneut verschickt und habe ich nachgeguckt der link war exakt die gleiche versandnummer
wie vorher die schon seit zwei wochen auf wird versendet steht und dann habe ich nicht reagiert
und anstatt dass aliexpress jetzt gesagt hätte ah das ist bestimmt alles gelöst und hat es
geschlossen hat aliexpress diesen fall geschlossen mit sie bekommen ihr geld zurück weil sie nicht
innerhalb eines tages geschrieben haben alles ist okay also ich hätte mich melden müssen alles ist
okay oder ich bekomme geld zurück es ist eigentlich eine ziemlich coole regelung ja ich habe einfach
gesagt okay geld zurück okay hey ich meine es ging auch nur um 40 euro oder sowas aber schon mal
nicht schlecht der hersteller war war danach aber gut was willst du nicht mein problem du hast du
hast dein 3d drucker material immer bei aliexpress geholt kann man kann man machen habe ich selbst noch
nicht bestellen du hast dir auch einen pb swiss 6500 exzellent und wie findest du also ich finde das
ding nice das ist mein mein go-to schrauben
dreh multifunktions ding man kann das meiste aller schraub schraub dinger mit diesem teil
easy abfackeln beste also worüber ich rede ist das ding hier pb swiss dieses teil gab es nämlich ein
angebot das teil mega mega nice set da sind wir das letzte mal drauf gekommen und es ist
relativ günstig gerade sogar mit 48 euro da sind wir da sind wir drauf drauf gekommen
weil irgendjemand in einem video ein schaumi elektronischen schraubendreher gezeigt hat
den ich ganz grausam fand da habe ich gesagt leute wenn überhaupt wenn ihr wirklich 40 50 euro ausgeben
wollt dafür dann kauft euch so ein ach so zoll bits nee wir brauchen die normalen also wir brauchen
nicht die die kekona nicht die kekona bits aber ich glaube die sind alle gleich groß ein viertel zoll bits ich gehe davon aus
ein viertel zoll bits ich gehe davon aus aber ich glaube die sind alle gleich groß ein viertel zoll bits ich gehe davon aus
ein viertel zoll bits ich gehe davon aus
die sind alle gleich groß. Also ich hab die mit den
europäischen Maßen. Aber das dürfte
alles, dürfte alles, alles passen.
Ja, das Ding ist sehr nice.
Du bekommst das Fach nicht so
easy auf. Echt?
Ja, man darf nicht oben ziehen.
Man muss unten. Du hast doch unten
extra so ein, äh,
so ne, so nen,
das ist doch unten extra so,
so Rillen, dass man,
guck mal hier, na gut,
da braucht man ein ordentliches Bild
davon. Mit dem Daumen hochschieben,
genau. Guck mal,
es gibt doch unten, die haben ja ne Scheiß-Bilder
davon, man.
Hat da irgendjemand mal, ja, hier sieht
man's, hier oben hast du, hier oben hast
du so Rillen zum, zum Aufschieben.
Hier.
Hier. Hast du so Rillen zum, zum
Aufschieben. Also das geht eigentlich.
Aber gut, man, ja.
Vielleicht muss man's ein paar mal auf, aufmachen hier, dass es
easy,
easier aufgeht.
Der sieht, nein, für Elektronik
Sachen ist da nix. Für, für
Elektronik Sachen ist da nix. Für Elektronik
Sachen ist wahrscheinlich auch vorne der,
hört man das,
der Schaft, keine Ahnung,
ein bisschen zu dick für, für wirklich
ganz kleine Elektronik Sachen.
Aber für das meiste, was man zum Schrauben braucht,
ja, ist da praktisch. Ich nehm den immer mit,
wenn ich nicht genau, wenn ich weiß oder wenn ich vermute,
dass ich was schrauben muss und nicht genau
weiß, was ich schrauben muss, nämlich immer dieses Ding
mit, sei, ich hab damit jetzt zum Beispiel
letztens mein Nummernschild festgeschraubt,
nicht Nummernschild, stimmt nicht, den Nummernschild
Halter festgeschraubt,
und
das ist äußerst, äußerst porke,
das Ding. Was sagt ihr, Vera?
Ist das der, dieser Clips,
der mit diesem ausfahrbaren Ding?
Ja. Ist das der?
Ne, das ist
einfach nur der Griff.
Also ich find das Ding sehr
praktisch. So,
stehen geblieben.
AliExpress.
Let's not waste any more time, and let's get started.
Was hast du für einen 3D-Drucker? Einen Mega-S, wie heißt dieses Ding, i3 Mega-S, i3 Mega-S, kann das sein, ja, das Teil, ist schon ein paar Jahre alt, heute würde ich mir einen anderen kaufen, aber für die damalige Zeit war das Ding preisheißungsmäßig absolut top.
... bei Rode und Schwarz.
Rode und Schwarz?
Schwarz.
Ich liebe meine Keysight-Testgear,
aber als Ingenieur
...
Let's start off with a special LED-Strip,
I got myself two meters of,
for around 16 Euro.
Okay, das ist
wie viel Meter?
2 Meter, 16 Euro,
das ist tatsächlich relativ günstig,
und es ist vor allem
so ein,
wo man die einzelnen LEDs nicht mehr so gut sieht,
das ist tatsächlich preis-leistungsmäßig
ziemlich gut das braucht aber auch abartig viel rom es sind okay ich sehe
schon ein paar nachteile davon es ist ein 12 volt 24 volt strip das heißt man
kann nicht direkt mit microcontroller anschließen aber es hat abfang für 630
led das ist das ist deutscher der channel betreiber 630 leds auf einem
meter das ist enorm viel leute das wirklich enorm viel deswegen kriegst du
das auch mit einem 55 volt strip nicht richtig hin mit einem 5 volt strip haben
die leds viel zu großen widerstand dass sie irgendwann nicht mehr die richtige
farbe haben nach ein paar metern beziehungsweise nach ein paar leds das
heißt es kann man mit normalen led strips machen ja geht das aber bei so
besonders so ultra dense led strips mit 630 led auf meter ist in 5 volt strip
keine allzu gute idee also ihr müsst euch mal überlegen das sind
1200 leds auf zwei meter das ist preis leistungstechnisch wirklich sehr
günstig im mit den color rgb ic was ic also ich kenne rgb und weiß was rgb ic
sein soll irgendjemand plan was rgb ic ist independent control multiple colors
aber kann das besser mischen oder so
ich dachte ich habe es alles gesehen und damit meine ich, dass wir unsere dummen single color oder
multikolor led strips haben, deren led breitheit ihr nur zusammen kontrollieren könnt und dann
habt ihr eure passende led strips ja wo ihr jede led individuell kontrollieren könnt ja
weil jeder kommt mit seinem eigenen kontroll ich sehe aber dieses neue led strip
von aliexpress ist etwas das ich noch nie gesehen habe und der große offensichtliche
Unterschied hier ist dass die leds die leds die leds die leds die leds die leds die leds die leds die leds
die leds
led strips heben auf, von sie und ich weiß es nicht richtig sie haben leider fodder
verdammt viel umلاut charakteristische
anícia competition ist 500
Hookschüchter
ja dasוםme ist nur der diffusor auf dem trick ist das ist eigentlich ziemlich
doof weil dann hast du ja immer noch dieses ganze kabel irgendwo du müsstest dann quasi eine hölle finden die hierödrum geht das ist ja blöd bei dem anderen kannst es halt den kompletten strippen in den diffusor stecken und gut ist
Of course diffuses the emitted light a lot better in comparison to normal LED-Strips.
I would still say it is not perfect though, but I think for many applications you would
not need an extra diffuser system.
I was also excited to see that it apparently features 600 Nits of LED-Strips.
Die WS-Strips haben den riesigen Vorteil, dass sie 5V sind, d.h. du kannst ja nirgends
beliebigen Mikrocontroller anschließen.
Dafür hast du das Problem, ab einer gewissen Länge bzw. einer gewissen Anzahl mit LEDs,
dass dein Voltage Drop oder der Widerstand von den LEDs zu hoch wird, dass die Farbe
nicht mehr richtig ist und du noch auf der anderen Seite injecten musst, was du bei 12
und 24V nicht hast und was du bei 630 LEDs pro Meter auch auf jeden Fall bräuchtest.
Also ein 5V-Strip?
Ja.
Mit 630 LEDs pro Meter kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Der ist dann nach den ersten paar Zentimetern stimmt ja die Farbe schon immer richtig.
Ja, nach 20 Zentimetern stimmt die Farbe nicht mehr.
Das muss ein 24V-Strip sein oder ein 12V-Strip sein, dass es gescheit funktioniert.
Aber 630 LEDs pro Meter ist schon enorm viel.
Ja.
Äh, sag mal.
Was ist jetzt?
Was?
Moment.
Was hat der Vivo angeschlossen?
Das ist der, das ist der neue?
Nee, 5V.
Das ist der neue.
12V.
Ja, okay.
Ja.
Die brauchen ein bisschen weniger, aber insgesamt brauchen die trotzdem verdammt viel bei 670
pro Meter.
Gut.
Da ist halt die 1.
der LED auch nicht so hell.
Gut.
Aber dafür hast du 670 auf dem Meter.
Kommt übrigens ungefähr auf die gleiche Helligkeit raus, würde ich mal sagen.
Also, man weiß ja nicht, wie viel davon jetzt in Licht umgewandelt wird.
Ich würde sagen, die Helligkeit ist tatsächlich ungefähr vergleichbar.
Ja, da hast du 144, da hast du 670, also rechnest du das mal mal 5.
Ich würde sagen, ungefähr gleich hell, so der 144er Strip versus der 670er Strip.
Vielleicht ist der 670er Strip minimal heller, ähm, aber trotzdem vollkommen im Rahmen eigentlich.
Aber ich meine, es braucht halt trotzdem, überlegt euch mal.
1,2, ähm, gut, wahrscheinlich volle, volle Pulle und volle Pulle Helligkeit und sowas.
Aber das ist, also, da brauchst du auch ein ordentliches Netzteil.
Ich meine, überlegt mal, volle Helligkeit, brauchst du ein 650 Watt Netzteil, ungefähr,
um den LED Strip, pfff, alter, na gut, oder sagen wir mal, du brauchst ein 12 Volt, 12
Volt Netzteil mit, äh, was brauchst du denn?
12 Volt.
Alter.
40?
Irgendwie 40 Ampere oder so?
Alter, das ist schon ein fettes Netzteil, was du dafür brauchst.
Für den, also, wenn du den kompletten Strip, wenn du den kompletten Strip auf, ja, äh,
wenn du den kompletten Strip auf volle Helligkeit laufen lassen willst, was man ja meistens
nicht will.
Also bemerkenswert, wenn man sich auf ihre Kraftkonsumption schaut.
Und letzten, aber nicht am besten, wie ihr vielleicht bereits bemerkt habt, kommt dieser
LED Strip auch mit IC.
Also, du kannst die RGB Farbe für jeden 7 cm des Strip kontrollieren.
Das ist viel weniger Resolution.
Okay, man, ah ja, okay, das, man kann damit zum Beispiel keine, äh, abgedrehten W-LED
Sachen machen, aber gut, je nachdem, was man machen will, braucht man das ja auch gar nicht.
Ja, ja, ja, du musst das, na gut, mehrere Netzteile einspeisen, ganz ehrlich, bei einem
Meter mit mehreren Netzteilen kann man machen, ist aber schon ein bisschen unangenehm, ja.
Weil der Vorteil von zwöl-, von 24- beziehungsweise 12-Volt-Strips sind ja gerade, dass du nicht
alle Nase, äh, oder alle, alle Furzlagen mal, äh, Power injecten musst.
.
Vorteil ist bessere Diffusion und das ist etwas, das ich mir selbst hinzufügen möchte.
Okay, wir gehen weiter mit dieser Box, die mit seltsamen-schleifigen Schleifen enthalten ist, die
die Dinger sind richtig nice. Bin ich mal gespannt, was er dazu sagt, als Elektronik-Pi-Fed.
Ja, die Dinger finde ich mega nice.
Lustig, dass ich genau das gleiche, ein paar Minuten, jetzt vor einer halben Stunde,
habe ich genau die gleiche Kombination gezeigt. Vago-Klemmen und Lötverbinder.
Also, wenn er das schon zeigt, dann taugt das auch was.
Da bin ich ja froh, dass ich nicht komplett einen Schnitt erzählt habe.
In Vergleich, sind sie nicht wasserfreundlich, arbeiten nicht mit vielen Schleifen-Sätzen
und ich denke auch, dass sie eine höhere Kontakt-Resistenz haben als die heat-schränkenden
Dinger.
Also musste ich sie natürlich probieren, die ich mit drei verschiedenen Schleifen-Sätzen
gemacht habe, indem ich einfach diese drei hier gezeigt habe.
Und für die meiste Zeit ging alles ziemlich leicht.
Selbst wenn die schrägsten Teile ein bisschen schwer mit dünnen Schrauben zu tun waren.
Aber wie Sie sehen können, formten diese Schleifkontaktion in allen Fällen erfolgreich.
Weil das ist, was sie hier im Grunde genommen machen.
Mit einer Heat-Schränk-Klemme, um die Schleifkontaktion zu melzen und dadurch zwei Schrauben zusammen zu füßen.
Und es scheint auch, als ob alle Verbindungen wasserfreundlich waren.
Und nach dem elektrischen Resistenz-Test mit einem von ihnen und einem Vago-Klemmen in Vergleich,
war es auch klar, dass die Schleifkontaktion nicht so gut war.
Es ist klar, dass es eine etwas niedrige Resistenz bietet, was bedeutet, dass sie für höhere
aktuelle Applikationen genutzt werden kann.
Also scheint es fast wie der ideale Konnektor zu sein, der auch meine...
Aber es ist nicht wirklich ein Hidden-Gem, weil ich meine, ich habe vor einer Stunde oder
einer halben Stunde darüber geredet, ich habe die schon seit zwei Jahren oder so, also
so hidden ist es nicht.
Stabil sind sie.
...Root-Force.
Aber lassen Sie mich Ihnen sagen, dass Sie nicht mehr als zwei Schrauben zusammenführen können,
Stiff-Kontaktionen sind aus der Frage.
Denn das hält nicht auf und es dauert auch eine Weile, um diesen Konnektor zu nutzen,
während Vago-Klemmen all das tun können und schnell zu benutzen sind.
Aber all in allem würde ich sie immer noch sehr empfehlen, vor allem für Fahrzeugausrüstungen
oder ähnliches.
Danach habe ich mir diesen kleinen 5-Volt-Fan für rund 12 Euro gekauft.
Ah ne, irgendwie habe ich gerade zu lol gelesen.
Weiß nicht genau warum.
Und I know, such a product does not really sound exciting at first, because it can
basically only cool off components or similar, but by simply flipping it around, it can also
be used as a fume extractor, whose size is a lot smaller than other commercial solutions
out there.
The only thing missing was a proper filter, for which I got myself a sheet of activated
coal that I cut to size and secured into place.
And yes, while I think this solution is definitely not perfect, it is well worth it for its low
price.
30 cm von mir weg.
Ja, genau.
Dass es mir nicht ins Gesicht hochdampft.
Das ist irgendwie.. den Raum pustet, ist ja okay, aber ich habe keinen Bock, dass es
mir in die Augen und ins Gesicht direkt reindampft.
And now..
Und da dieses Gadget nicht viel Strom auslöst, ist es ziemlich gut aus Acrylglas und Aluminium hergestellt und der Inblase Boost Converter funktioniert akzeptabel gut, würde ich es eher empfehlen, denke ich.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt zu drei Produkten auf einmal, die im Grunde alle das selbe machen, aber bevor ich...
Soll das ein Abisolierer-Ding sein, oder?
Lass mich dir sagen, dass es...
Das taugt doch im Leben nix! Billiger AliExpress-Abisolierer, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das was taugt.
...all rather cheap. The most expensive one was 10 Euro. And I got them because I was a bit frustrated by my Okari.
Alter, Chad! Wenn ich so Zeug immer lese, warum gibt es immer so viele Leute, die das alles immer besser wissen? Ich meine, es funktioniert doch, was er macht, ja?
Okay, ich meine, sicherlich kannst du immer noch irgendwas optimieren, aber egal, was es ist.
Was ist es eigentlich?
Was ist es eigentlich mit Technik und Elektronik-Zeug, dass sobald irgendjemand was lötet, ein Kabel irgendwo reinsteckt, irgendwas zusammenklemmt, was auch immer, auch wenn es vollkommen okay ist, dass irgendjemand um die Ecke kommt und sagt, oh, das ist aber schlecht und oh, wenn ich das meinem Meister zeigen würde, der würde mich ohrfeigen, so nach dem Motto, was ist es mit Elektronik-Zeug immer, dass die Leute so abgehen lässt da drauf?
Ich meine, ist doch vollkommen okay, was er gemacht hat.
Klar, du kannst immer irgendwas verbessern noch, aber trotzdem.
Ich weiß noch, Leute, könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, wo ich den Rechner im Stream zusammengebaut habe, zumindest teilweise, auf dem übelst wackeligen Stand, ich habe nichts wirklich gesehen, also es war schon unter erschwerten Bedingungen, ja?
Und im Chat immer die Leute, die übelst wichtig getan haben, Haarrisse im Mainboard, Max, Haarrisse im Mainboard.
Warte, ich benutze den Rechner jetzt seit ungefähr einem halben Jahr und von den Haarrissen im Mainboard habe ich noch nichts gemerkt.
Das war, oh Gott, das war, das mache ich nicht mehr, den Zusammenbau-Stream, ey.
Whose job it is to remove the outer insulation from my electrical wires?
No, don't get me wrong, the Yokari works perfectly fine with...
Yokari, Beste, habe ich auch, der abisoliert Champ, Beste.
Beste.
Standard-Haus-Cable-Sizes.
But as soon as something gets bigger or smaller, it suddenly becomes pretty useless.
Du musst, du trollst doch jetzt, oder?
Ich meine, dass irgendjemand, ich meine, guck mal, der Typ hat 1,8 Millionen Subs und macht englischsprachige Videos als deutsches.
Also so mies kann das schon mal nicht sein, was er macht.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, es gibt tausende Comments bei ihm, so nach dem Motto, haha, lul, man hört, dass du Deutscher bist, haha, lul.
Du hast ein bisschen mehr, du hast ein bisschen mehr, du hast ein bisschen mehr, du hast ein bisschen mehr, du hast ein bisschen mehr.
Du hast das falsch ausgesprochen.
Ja und?
Ich meine, wenn es für einen Channel reicht, seriously, wenn es für einen Channel reicht, einen englischsprachigen Channel mit 1,8 Millionen Subscriber zu generieren,
dann ist das vollkommen fein für so ziemlich alles, was er macht.
Naja, okay.
Was auch immer, also, ich kenne das auch hier im Stream, sind auch immer die Leute, so nach dem Motto, lul, weißt du, wenn ich mal, manchmal haben wir noch ein paar englische Zuschauer, ja, und ich antworte denen auf Englisch, da kommen die Leute auch immer,
immer richtig hier im Stream rein, so, lul, Max, nice, englisch, haha, lul, lul.
Und das ist der Grund, warum ich diese drei ausprobieren wollte, die, laut ihren Produktdeskriptionen, auch diesen Job machen sollten.
Ich habe aber schnell bemerkt, dass der kleine, gelbe war ein absolut schlechtes Verkauf.
Also, ich hätte nicht, ich würde, ich würde ehrlich gesagt erst gar nicht damit rechnen, dass 1,50 Euro Wire Stripper von AliExpress irgendwas taugen können.
Weil es nur mit dünneren Datenkabeln funktioniert.
Und seine Qualität ist nicht großartig.
Der grüne, auf der anderen Seite, funktioniert auch mit dickeren Wiren.
Aber hier habe ich das Problem, dass das Verändern zwischen Kabelzahlen sehr, sehr lange dauert für mich.
Und das bringt mich zu dem roten, der ein bisschen günstig aussehen könnte.
Ich meine, muss ich auch mal in die andere Richtung reinversetzen.
Guck mal, wenn du einen YouTube-Channel hast, du hast dann irgendwie, du hast ja nicht nur einen Kommentar, du hast dann tausende dazu.
Und irgendwann nervt es halt einfach nur.
Und wahrscheinlich ist ihm oftmals auch bewusst, wenn er Sachen falsch ausspricht.
I mean, so what?
But it works wonderfully.
Simply select the hole, where your wire barely fits through.
Alter, jetzt ist aber mal gut.
Ich glaube, so ein Ding muss sich daheim noch nie abisolieren.
Was ist das für ein mega fettes Ding?
Push down and pull.
Super simple and after doing quite a bit of testing, I can also confirm that the inner insulation of the cable never got damaged, which is really important.
So all in all, I initially did not expect that, but after testing, I would actually recommend the red wire stripper tool.
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde mir irgendwas ordentliches kaufen.
While the other ones not so much.
Moving on though.
Next I got myself these two PCBs with integrated battery holder.
Also es war was zum Thema Englisch, ja.
Ich gucke gerade nebenbei so ein bisschen Serie.
Das ist wirklich krass mit englischem Akzent.
Ich habe mir mal einen Probemonat Apple TV geholt.
Da wollen wir mal gucken, was die so haben.
Ich werde das nicht weiterführen.
Und das ist eine Serie, da geht es um irgendeinen englischen Fußballklub.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt.
Vielleicht kennt ihr das.
Jetzt um irgendeinen englischen Fußballklub.
Und Leute, ich sage euch, die Akzente sind echt nicht mehr normal, ja.
Der eine hat übelst krassen Ami-Akzent.
Dann haben sie irgendwie ihre Fußballspieler, die was auch immer für englische Akzente reden.
Und dann machen sie irgendwelche englischen Insider-Jokes.
Leute, ich muss gefühlt jeden Dialog-Untertitel anschalten und gucken, Alter, was haben die jetzt gesagt?
Aber lernt man auch ab und zu ein bisschen was.
Warum nicht auf Deutsch gucken?
Weil ich mir die Serie am liebsten im Original angucke.
Und ich mir vorstelle, viele Gags gehen auf Deutsch auch ein bisschen unter.
Ich finde die Serie tatsächlich ganz nice.
Das ist so eine richtige, so eine richtige Feel-Good-Serie.
Ja, selbst die, selbst so die übelsten Wichser sind eigentlich ganz nette Leute.
Also das ist wirklich, wenn man schlecht drauf ist und hat sich so eine Folge angeguckt von 30 Minuten,
dann ist man eigentlich ganz gut drauf meistens.
Aber du musst halt, du musst halt, auch wenn man die wirklich versteht, denkst du dir so, hä, was hat der jetzt?
Da musst, also ich gucke die mit Untertitel, aber ich gucke die Untertitel halt auf Englisch.
Ja, also ich hab, ähm, ich hab die, ich hab die Serie auf Englisch und die Untertitel auf Englisch.
Das sollte schon alles über die Dialekte und sowas aussagen, ja.
Also, die reden halt auch übel schnell teilweise.
Aber, aber da lernt man ein bisschen was, ja.
Vor allem, so, so, so, so random.
Auch, also da haben wir ein bisschen Radewendungen auf Englisch, die du normalerweise nie hörst.
Okay.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Ein.
Raspberry Pi USV mit zwei Dings Batterien.
Wie heißen diese, diese, diese E-Zigarettenbatterien?
Ach da unten steht es ja hier, 18650.
Das sind ja die Dinger, die man auch in E-Zigaretten reinmacht.
For Euro.
Supercheap.
They are in fact a UPS, aka uninterruptible Power supply.
oder USV, unterbrechungsfreie Stromversorgung, wie wir das auf deutsch nennen.
Die stecken glaube ich auch im Tesla, die stecken in so gut wie allen Akkus drin.
Halt, ähm, ziemlich, ziemlich viele zusammen.
Also so ein Teil habe ich auch gekauft und, ähm, ich habe allerdings nur einen mit 5 Volt Output, da geht auch nur eine Batterie rein.
Das hält, das hält ein bisschen mit dem Raspberry Pi, also man kann den Raspberry Pi damit jetzt nicht irgendwie eine Woche draußen betreiben, so keine Ahnung, 4, 5 Stunden oder so, wenn er nicht funktioniert.
Aber für mal kurz überbrücken vom Stromausfall, gerade weil Raspberry Pis dazu neigen, bei einem Stromausfall, dass dann manchmal die SD-Karte neu geflasht werden muss, ist so Dinge, finde ich persönlich sehr praktisch.
So ein Ding, so ein Ding habe ich auch, auch sehr praktisches Ding zum, zum Debuggen von USB-Anschlüssen.
Ich war sehr überrascht, wie viel Geräusch der beklagte 5-Volt-DC-Output mitkommt.
Ich meine, das ist so viel, dass es mehr wie ein Funktionsgenerator ist.
Okay, also ein bisschen konstanter 5 Volt hätte ich mir jetzt schon erwartet.
Was ist denn das, Alter?
Und das selbe Problem gilt auch für das 12-Volt-Board, das ich habe.
Was, übrigens, beide haben eine 5-Star-Rating auf 1.
Ja, das hat, 5-Star-Rating AliExpress heißt ja nix.
So this Boost Converter Design here comes with some serious problems.
And I can definitely not recommend it.
Because a few devices will not be happy with such an output voltage.
And with that being said, we come to the last product, which is this.
Wenn du ein Raspberry Pi per USB dranhängst, sollte der das wahrscheinlich schon selbst machen.
Die haben bestimmt ein paar Kondensatoren am Input.
Und die meisten Leute wollen halt nicht selbst da dran löten.
Und ich muss sagen, da bin ich auch nicht elektronisch, da habe ich auch nicht genug Ahnung.
Weil ich wüsste beispielsweise gar nicht, was ich da für einen Kondensator nehmen soll.
Keine Ahnung.
So Dinger können durchaus praktisch sein.
Ich habe sowas ganz furchtbar in billig, ohne Display.
Ich habe so einen regelbaren Konverter.
Und wenn ich was einstellen muss, hänge ich dann immer mal...
Dann hänge ich dann immer mal...
Meinen Multimeter dran.
Gucke auf, was da Output steht.
Drehe da ein bisschen dran rum, bis es passt.
Und dann schließe ich das an, was ich machen muss.
Also ich benutze mein Multimeter als Display.
Ja, sowas mit einem ordentlichen Display zum Einstellen, könnte ich mir tatsächlich auch mal kaufen.
Ja.
AliExpress-Beschreibung ist immer ein bisschen Paintschamp.
Ich meine, die schreiben da viel Mist drauf, wenn der Tag lang ist.
So as a first test I hooked up a 24V power supply to its input and played around with
its knob and display bit to not only find out that I can easily set a current and voltage
limit but also that in this case the max output voltage is only around 23V.
That is of course because this thing is a buck converter meaning it can only step down
the input voltage.
But nevertheless the voltage output and current limit values seem to be accurate and even
after pushing this thing close to its limit with a current flow of 15A it only heated
up slightly.
Nice.
I of course also measured some input and output power values to create this efficiency graph
here that tells us for example that with the noise.
As a comparison here is the noise of a proper lab bench power supply.
They are worlds apart.
So even though this small power supply does offer a lot for its low price I cannot fully
recommend it after seeing its output voltage but you do you and maybe give it a shot anyway.
And with that being said we come to the end of this episode.
There were not too many recommendations from me.
But I still hope you enjoyed it.
By the way some of these suggestions come straight from my Discord server which you can
also join by following the link in the video description.
They do not vary as much as the ones in the description.
I will see you guys in the next video.
Bye Bye.
Bye.